going from San Francisco to Miami it's
like going from third world to First SF
in Miami are kind of like Peaks into the
future so you have like the Florida man
Trope but guess what Florida man has
high speed rail Florida man can afford a
house to raise a family in Florida man
has Law and Order California man not so
much you literally went to Ukraine a
colleague of mine and he's like hey why
don't we go I'm like okay fine I'll ride
with you he ended up eventually
interviewing his lunch I had to go do a
podcast of all things so I had to go do
broken and Joe Rogan pulled you out of I
know
Bitcoin it is probably the most American
ethos but
we have if there is a crypto Century
America should dominate because it's
like the most American thing ever all
right guys bang bang I've got Antonio
here with me uh I thought a great police
to start this conversation uh you
recently came to Miami which you've done
many many times before and you took a
photo and it's a guy with a American
flag draped over him uh and he seems to
be walking kind of away and the Tweet
was like Hey there was no English spoken
but these people obviously appreciate
the freedoms that are afforded them in
uh the United States and they seem to be
incredibly happy to now be in Miami in
the United States what was the
significance of that too like why did
you one notice it and two think that hey
look if I share this like it might uh
start a conversation yeah so I do come
to Miami a lot and I was actually raised
here so I started coming here pretty
early but yeah so I just came into the
airport Miami airport is always
fascinating because Miami is fascinating
right and so it's just the amount of
people and God knows what else that
flows through Miami is just incredible
so I get off and it was like late on a
Saturday so it's pretty quiet and I see
this sort of family ambling through and
there's a number of American flags like
the one behind you the guy's kind of
wearing it almost like a shawl there's a
number of balloons there's a sort of
celebratory atmosphere I'm like what is
going on and I sort of like follow along
kind of eavesdrop a little bit it's like
fresh off the island very you know Cuban
common Cuban accent and I think they had
just arrived and you know basically they
had gotten out somehow that's a lot of
the balloons said welcome and uh you
know as you know Miami's it's
interesting because of course it's it's
this weird Venn diagram intersection
between like anglo-america and Latin
America and yet it is super patriotic
you see American flags everywhere and uh
yeah I think there's people that just
gotten from Cuba and uh you know they're
starting their new life in America when
a lot of What's called the tech and
finance industry started to ReDiscover
Miami which you know people had uh in
other Generations known about Florida in
general uh but over the last two three
years a lot of people moved here a lot
of people started to visit more often uh
one of the things they always talk about
is like hey this doesn't feel like
America and they're talking specifically
about language about culture about kind
of uh even the way that people act the
thoughts that they have uh how important
is it for the United States still to
have these pockets of uh areas where
like it is The Melting Pot of so many
different cultures so I agree with that
on one hand it doesn't feel American on
the other hand it's like the most
American city in America in my opinion
right
um it's funny yeah so I was raised here
I lived until I was 18 and Miami the 80s
and 90s was very different than what you
see today in some ways it was similar in
some ways it was very different but I
remember thinking oh I went I went to
the United States for college right I
went to school in the Midwest and it's
finally when I got there I realized man
I was not raised in the United States of
America like Heartland America is very
different than Miami a lot of different
cultural assumptions but on the other
hand there's something so American about
Miami right like no one cares where
you're from there's like a super strong
hustle culture I mean talk about
diversity here you have real diversity
So Yesterday long story I was here for
like a political conference and I'm
doing a thing on and
um I I go I'm in Aventura which is a
very Jewish part of Miami and I go to a
Judaica store because I was buying some
stuff and then I go to a kosher pita
place and the woman greets me an
Argentinian spin right and I there were
Latin American Jews that ran a kosher
falafel place in Miami and it's just
this constant weird mix of anything of
everything right happening and you know
it's very business oriented right as you
know
um and so yeah I mean aesthetically it
feels non-american and that you know
good luck getting by without Spanish but
on the other hand
it is so American yeah but it's just
capitalism right like capitalism is the
DNA that runs through this entire place
and it feels uh similar to like maybe
when I was growing up people were like
uh oh get to New York uh Wall Street
like that that whole world uh to some
degree was aspirational but it was
unreachable whereas it feels like here
this whole like hustle culture or
whatever uh no man it's it's not about
like how do I create an asset management
firm it's like I literally might go
start a car wash I might start a
restaurant I might start you know
whatever but like there is a path to the
quote-unquote American dream yeah yeah I
think so and I have to say I think that
hustle culture probably came so my
parents were Cuban Exiles that came uh
when they were teens I was born in the
United States but they came right after
the revolution in the 60s as many did my
father walked out of um what's now
called Freedom Tower which you've
probably seen which is these this old
kind of ornate it now looks dwarf by the
other buildings Miami was the original
skyscraper in Miami and he walked out of
there what was then the Cuban Refugee
Center which is now a museum to the
Cuban Exiles and uh you know as it would
often remind me he walked in here with
three things in his pocket a um a bus
ticket to Chicago a Spanish English
dictionary and a plastic safety razor
that's it that's what he came came to
the United States with and uh you know
he he worked in real estate which is
like a whole thing here and um yeah I
mean it's very much that hustle culture
that build that get ahead
um that the city has just had for
decades did he talk about Cupid all
growing oh yeah of course like uh I
think a lot about So a family comes here
and uh they're kids so they're first
generation American but uh obviously
they have a very different perspective
of uh what America is what it means the
significance of it the whole idea of
like draping a flag over yourself
walking through the airport uh there are
parts of the country who would call you
racist right for for the flag kind of
becoming this like symbol in some
people's eyes on the other hand it is
the symbol of freedom and and it's a
single physical item that frankly has no
thoughts has it you know it's not
sentient being it's just being used in
these different ways like what was it
like growing up with Cuban Exile parents
yeah I mean
somewhat less so now because again
Miami's become so Cosmopolitan that
there's lots of different influences
that you see here but back in the I mean
the Cuban part of Miami very much feels
like this weird American Suburban reboot
of like pre-revolutionary Cuba so one of
the weird sort of almost contradictions
of the human eyes dog experiences on the
one hand they're super patriotic
um often tend to vote right of Center
but on the other hand they absolutely
maintain in the most like Shameless way
their Cuban identity so I went to Belen
Jesuit which is a prep school which was
the same high school that Fidel Castro
went to when he kicked out the Catholic
priest when he took power they came to
Miami and they set up the exact same
school and it became exact same thing
there was in Cuba which was the sort of
you know whatever a very conservative
Catholic School
um and the same networks the same
families are often here as they are on
the other side and so they they
recreated in many ways pre-revolutionary
cubes and then they've maintained alive
like they will just shamelessly expect
you to drink Cuban coffee like Starbucks
what are you talking about of course not
like this is just the way the world
works there's like everything is
suffused by Latin American culture
American Business culture and rule of
law and this is the way the world works
but on the other hand
American flags everywhere
um and they definitely don't have the
sort of I think we're getting at is the
sort of fashionable
um sort of self-loathing or almost
questioning of the meaning of America it
doesn't have any play here because again
here they act they actually know what
the alternative is the alternative is
Cuba the alternative is Venezuela the
alternative is all sorts you know a
world of pain that they left behind and
to and to them this place seems
magnificent yeah one of the things I've
heard people in different ways say over
and over again is like uh America seems
to want to experiment and uh we don't
need to do that like we we've already
seen how those experiments run and so
like this is the best any human uh group
of people has figured out so far like
let's keep riding this wave
um but what was the big difference when
you went to the Midwest like that's
fascinating to have Cupid Exile parents
grow up in Miami and then uh you go to
the Midwest like you're just lost well
it was it was weird well it was it was
probably a mistake in the end for other
reasons but it was weird in the sense my
parents went to the Midwest so the way
the exhausting worked if you had family
here
um you would be sent to wherever your
family was my both my parents were sent
to Indiana and Illinois and then they
eventually ended up going to UIUC
University Illinois Champaign so in
their mind like regular America was like
Frozen in Amber it was like post
Eisenhower Mad Men 1960s America where
you went to like a Midwestern State
School and everything was fine and
America just functioned that way and
that was just like the image the head of
America of course after after college
they went to California in the 70s I
like to experience some of Greater but
then they came here and that's it that's
the image that's stuck in their head so
to them going to a big State School in
the midwest is just what one did of
course in reality it's not kind of the
case anymore
um but yeah I know it was you know it
was one of these rural college town type
things
uh dated a local girl who was raised on
a farm I mean the full the full picture
the full sitcom right
um the full Netflix show
um I don't know it was just yeah it was
wild it was a little it was it was
different and then and then I went to
California and again I was still kind of
a Miami boy and that I didn't understand
you know California has a lot of
Hispanic culture as well it's very
different it's a very different
interaction than it is in Miami and so
um yeah it was it was a learning
experience I mean again Miami was just
very different it was very it was much
more provincial I mean there's also
pretty internet right if you want to
read the New York Times you have to find
a copy and buy it otherwise you wouldn't
get it
um and so yeah many ways I lived I did
lead a sheltered life until until later
well it's interesting because uh when I
was in Silicon Valley I worked with a
number of people who had family in Miami
uh one person thinking in particular uh
is Venezuelan you know full Venezuelan
experience uh has friends who uh are not
so well liked in the country by the uh
existing political regime
um and I remember saying to him at some
point like yeah I think I'm gonna move
to Miami and he was like why would you
ever do that right because he was just
like that like everyone who gets there
then wants to leave team it's this it's
it's whatever uh and so it does feel
like there's almost this rediscovering
of some of this oh yeah yeah uh to some
degree but it also pits it and I've seen
you talk about this before uh where
Florida and California seem to be headed
in two different directions and like
highlighting two different Futures yeah
like when you analyze those two things
like how do you break that down so for
started I think you're Venezuelan
friends thing is a very common
experience I had the same experience
when like Dalian did his tweet and
everyone got excited about Miami like I
hadn't been back very often to be honest
and again Miami used to be somewhat
provincial and a little backwatery
um I mean Cosmopolitan in its own way
but also like not part of like the New
York SF Continuum no but nobody who is
ambitious like super ambitious would
stick around
um it was usually your more normal
friends who stuck around everyone else
left so but that's that has radically
changed right just yeah I mean I just
came from Panther Coffee in Wynwood
which Winwood used to be kind of a
ghetto by the way was not a nice place
to live at all and there's some like
somebody yammering in German next to me
at this like third wave coffee place
that did not exist 15 20 years ago right
it was impossible for that to exist
um but yeah in terms of the Futures it's
funny that like I wasn't gonna tweet
this because I'll get jumped on it but
your followers probably don't care but
it's funny like when you used to go from
Miami to like the United States again
you used to feel you're going a little
bit developing world to First World a
little bit because Miami's a little
rough on the edges and like now going
from San Francisco to Miami it's like
the opposite yes it's like going from
third world to First and it's like oh
look everything kind of works there's
Law and Order it's not like a disaster I
forgot who I saw it but just recently I
saw a tweet it was going viral and it
was a thread but the first tweet said
something to the effect of like uh
Silicon Valley everyone was moving there
there was tons of growth uh there was
actually quite a bit of uh housing being
built in various ways you saw cranes all
the time uh like all these things
everyone's like okay things are going
well and now they went back three years
later and they're like holy [ __ ] there's
crime everywhere this is an absolute uh
uh declining City uh from an
infrastructure standpoint from a safety
standpoint all these different things
and like people have left and it reminds
me I think it was uh Keith were boy who
talked about like Detroit Detroit used
to be booming no it's not go ahead I
mean yeah I don't quite buy Keith's line
he obviously has very strong views um it
why do you disagree
well because Detroit
isn't like embedded in the middle of a
natural Paradise called Northern
California for one right for as much as
trash we might talk about San Francisco
and it definitely has real problems the
surrounding area is basically Paradise I
mean you can go skiing and surfing on
the same day you've got wine country I
mean it's the city itself is still
gorgeous in its own weird way yes uh
it's not going to be Detroit right and
and to be honest San Francisco has been
in a boom bust cycle since 1849. right
this is hardly new this is just another
downturn
um but but I do but I do agree that
something is kind of flipped and Florida
has become much more serious right it's
like it's weird because in the outside
world you have like the Florida man
Trope and Florida man definitely does
Exist by the way in like Northern
Florida in the Panhandle like Florida
man has Wheel but guess what in South
Florida Florida man has High-Speed Rail
Florida man can afford a house to raise
a family in Florida man has pretty good
Public Schools right Florida man has Law
and Order California man not so much or
at least SF man doesn't right and so
like the tropes about like Florida's
this joke it's like no Florida's
actually pretty well run
um and so yeah I mean things have have
um have definitely changed and again you
know I don't wish California ill like I
have to stay there I have family there
so I hope the city sort of recovers but
it's it's weird walking around like
South Park Soma which you probably did
back in the day 10 years ago like
literally the entire consumer internet
that you cared about was within like a
three by seven block area and you'd walk
through South Park and there are the
founders of Airbnb and there's a sequoia
partner and it's like there was this
vibrant hum of like everything happening
in one place and that's no longer the
case yeah I literally remember when uh I
flew out to interview at Facebook and uh
they were like yeah and then you're
gonna stay in Mountain View and you're
gonna come to the campus and I'll say I
remember walking on campus and being
like holy [ __ ] this is literally a
different world uh I grew up in North
Carolina like that there's nothing like
that right and um when you then saw how
many people the other thing that was
really interesting was everyone was in
person and uh I was really talking to
somebody I worked with at Facebook and
it was like there was all these people
who were there and you kind of sort of
knew it was a special moment or a
special group like no one knew what
everyone was going to go do later but
like you're like I have never worked
with this many smart people who uh have
this velocity and just seemed like get
[ __ ] done like this right and now those
people obviously have gone and done
amazing things you worked at Facebook
you worked a number of different tech
companies does it feel like the like
in-person high octane group of people
all there together like is that changing
now and now you've got remote you've got
people in different Geographic locations
like like how do you think about it I
mean if you look at the occupancy raised
for commercial real estate in San
Francisco they're super low so like the
numbers don't lie that a lot of people
have moved out of the city that said
I've started so I just raised around for
a company hopefully we'll talk about it
um one of the investors is this uh thing
called South Park Commons a bunch of
Facebook you probably know who it is
Aditya and Russia and so they've got
like a space literally on South Park
um I think either inside or next to the
building where Twitter was founded and
um you know there's also a lot of like
great talent in San Francisco that
hasn't left because a lot of them still
have family or you know real estate and
there's a lot of like really smart Fang
people who've like dealt with global
scale infra kind of sitting around
waiting to see what's next right and
they're not going to move and they're
still there and they prefer in-person
work and uh I don't know I plan on
staying in San Francisco for the company
again I sort of have to
um but I don't think it's a terrible
idea either from a recruitment
perspective yeah uh what about the
leadership so obviously DeSantis I know
that uh you saw him speak yes yeah
yesterday uh and then Newsome I saw uh
he's been running ads in Florida he gave
a speech what is up with that why is he
running ads in Florida what is that well
I have my theories I'm curious what you
think or what the viewers I don't know
but let me tell you what he said in a
recent interview which uh uh in a very
politician way he was like uh I don't
like bullies and Abbott and DeSantis are
bullies and therefore uh I need somebody
needs to stand up to them and he was
like why are you gonna run for president
he goes uh right now I'm focused on
California and like in all talking
points whatever uh and they're like so
like why are you running ads in Florida
and he's like I don't like bullies and
so it was like uh okay either you're
running for president or like you're
wasting money maybe both right but like
what is going on here what is yours
that's just as if the scientist is like
running around wedging people like what
does he mean my Defenders is being a
bully
um yeah I mean I I think I tweeted it
yesterday that I think
SF in Miami are kind of like Peaks into
the future for those respective
political philosophies for better and
worse and I think yeah I think Newsom
DeSantis have come to be the face of
those world right now that Trump is kind
of fading to the background and the
whole front machine is kind of falling
apart you know I think DeSantis and
Newsome are like the sort of the face of
of those different movements and it's
it's very different attitudes like the
Santa's speech yesterday
um you know he hits on all his points
and he hits on you know he's released
campaign ads that more or less hit his
talking points and it's a very different
message than Newsom yeah what's
fascinating to me also is obviously
people self-select uh into certain
political ideologies and and if these
two things are going to go in opposite
directions they'll go live in certain
cities uh but the people in the middle
like there's a lot more conversation
around inflation around taxes around
like like what happens to my personal
wallet or pocketbook uh and I have a
friend who's lived in California his
entire life and he's like dude when it
went over 50 taxes he's like
psychologically I was like this sucks
right like like enough he's at 49 I was
chill 51. I'm I'm out right like
whatever for whatever reason and I do
think that there's a lot of things on
both sides a little bit of glial that
like people are just waking up to it and
it's less about like is the difference
between 49 51 really that big no
psychologically though huge huge
difference and obviously it's
exasperated by things like uh uh locking
people in their homes and how they
treated masks No Mess whatever
but like you are just watching the Polar
Opposites play out here and I do Wonder
like do we ever get a return to the
center or is it just going to be more
and more extreme over time yeah the tax
thing is kind of interesting so I I you
know I have a house in Northern Nevada
which is where I officially live and uh
the real estate brokers are like yeah we
have so many California clients and they
show up saying 13 13 and that's the top
state income tax rate in California it's
like 13
um say that the tax yeah I mean I don't
want to go to 18. I'll do that okay yeah
that's what they put forward I don't
know if they're gonna get it passed but
18 would put it at like people would be
paying like 56 57 yeah yeah and I think
the weird thing is like people don't
necessarily mine high taxes as long as
they get something for it but then you
look at California's infra and it's like
a joke I mean floater is a lot I I don't
mean to be a Standish but just reporting
on what he said in this thing and kind
of Stack is like look we have like
better roads like better Public Schools
you can go to college for six thousand
dollars a year here and no state income
tax right and you look at that and you
compare it to the California deal it's
like well what are you what are you
getting for that I mean as a side thing
by the way it's just kind of interesting
I tried living in Europe but I'm one of
the few people who actually lived in
Europe I have a new passwords I can go
live there and it's not you think I
actually penciled out the taxes the US
is actually not a low tax regime at all
like the total taxes you pay in
California are comparable to the taxes
you pay in Spain and Germany but again
there you have sort of a national Fabric
and infrastructure that you pay for in
like in the United States you don't so
yeah I think people are getting yeah I
think it's a symbolic thing of like wait
you're selling 51 cents of every dollar
goes to the state and like in addition
to that I'm paying for private schooling
and this and that to actually avoid the
deteriorating infrastructure of the
state well I'm out yeah well this idea
of like you are buying something right
you most people don't think of it that
way but when you start but you are you
are buying something right and I don't
know I think American Federalism is good
and I think different states should run
their business their Affairs different
ways and I'd yeah why is Newsome running
ads in Florida it's like what do you
care I mean I'm like if you don't have
to deal with the santis in Florida then
don't deal with it go run your own State
and we'll see right and if you look at
the numbers the numbers don't lie
California has led the leaderboard in
like domestic immigration and Florida
and Texas have been tied for first and
second in domestic immigration and so if
California is a great place to lead to
live why is everybody leaving right well
how do you feel about some of these
let's take foreign Texas as an example
uh and didn't mean to talk so much about
politics but whatever uh how much of
like their uh interjection into like
social issues versus like more of the
legislation and business issues like
it's just a natural product of the time
that we live in social media and and
that gets headlines and drives
conversation versus like uh I don't know
going after Disney or uh having certain
types of policies like those actually
keep people or attract people to come
move to your state and drive more
Revenue
yeah I don't know I mean I I think it's
funny again I sound like I'm some sort
of the Santa shell or something but it
is
definitely not no I'm not absolutely not
showing for any politician um but he did
in terms of the thinking it's
interesting one of the numbers that
struck stuck in my head because he cited
a bunch of lists of like Florida
victories and one is and I don't even
know where you pull these numbers a
total influx of adjusted gross income
apparently you can measure that somehow
which is interesting which you know is
rather than people it's like dollar
signs and I forget the numbers he cited
and I have a recording of it but
basically decided that Florida has one
of the highest influx of adjusted gross
income as if he was a growth marketer as
like an app developer saying oh the rpus
are really high and the time
right no it was like this and it's
getting like a growth it's like wow
that's I guess that's interesting way to
think about it and I guess Florida does
think about it that way because you know
there is a lot of fast money in Florida
in the sense of like we you know people
come here because they like the
financial climate and there's a liquid
real estate market in condos and stuff
and a lot of Latin Americans have the
same thing right and so um it's
interesting he thinks about it well you
even see like you know it's important
for us to talk about the downsizes as
well so just in the city of Miami
prices have skyrocketed for Real Estate
rent
even just everyday items some of that is
uh being experienced on global scale
even a national scale uh in terms of the
loose monetary policy like all that type
of stuff but like there's very much a
thing of uh how many people made more
than I don't know 200 000 a year that
lived in Miami three years ago and then
now like a lot more I don't know what
the numbers are but a lot more uh so
naturally the average price of a lot of
these things goes up and and continues
to Trend upwards uh and so the impact on
the people who have been here before
that happened is not good right they
start to feel like hey I can't afford
this why is everything's getting so
expensive my income is not going up at
the same rate and we've seen uh that on
a national scale but but I think it's
exasperated in Miami and so you start to
look at this and you're like okay cool
like yes that is a great stat to point
at and cheer for uh because as a state
level like you're improving but then
there's real impact and like how do you
deal with that I don't know if there's
states or cities that know how to deal
with some of that going on I mean build
more housing way to do it although in
South Florida you're someone limited
right because Miami expands to the west
of Everglades and then that's it there's
only so much space West you can go
um
yeah I don't know you know it's funny
one of the weird things about like this
whole Tech thing when DeLeon did is all
Miami Tech week because it was in a
pre-existing Miami Tech week that got
pissed off that like the founders fun
people came in and now you want to
interject myself into that drama but I
found it interesting that people were
assuming the attack of like oh these are
like gentrifiers who are coming in it's
like
and it's odd that people were claiming
like oh I'm the real Miami when like
that is the most unmiami attitude ever
right because like people have been
coming here and gentrifying or carpet
bagging since forever I mean that's what
my parents did right everybody everyone
there's always a new generation everyone
finds obnoxious that shows up and kind
of
you know
um projects their reality on it I
remember when I was a little kid it was
funny
you know again Miami used to be very
different than now but I just remember
there used to be bumper stickers on cars
that said can the last American who lose
Miami please bring down the flag right
because Miami was getting totally
dominated by human Aesthetics and again
I you know they're completely just
unself-consciously what they are they're
a little obnoxious frankly and they just
impose like their culture not impose but
they just they don't give a [ __ ] they're
not going to try to meet they're super
American but they're not gonna like you
know which is American
place right right it's like a Godfather
too when the Italians are having like
their San Gennaro festival and like no
one's sitting there trying to integrate
with anything they're just like oh of
course we're gonna carry this Festival
from Naples or whatever and have it in
New York of course we are it's the same
thing in Miami yeah but I think that
this and when I saw your Tweet like I
almost tweeted and then didn't and we
could talk about why but uh I was like
man Miami seems to be one of the places
where like people are still understand
the importance of America the uh value
of like true Freedom not not the
[ __ ] like hey I can go outside
whatever but like actually hey I just
came from a really bad place this place
is way better and I am proud of the fact
that I either got here that I live here
that these ideals are what I am choosing
to go in and live within uh and it does
feel like maybe Florida and Texas
specifically but also some other places
around the United States like they're
trying to amp that back up because they
feel like uh that's being lost on a
national scale yeah yeah I mean I
remember one of the sort of Boomer
phrases my father used to use a lot
somebody mentioned this on Twitter as
well that's like people used to say oh
it's a free country right and the idea
is typically like usually say
something's like well that's not sounds
kind of dumb but whatever like what do I
care no skin off my back and sometimes
we don't say that anymore we don't say
you know somebody does something dumb
but you know it's a free country it's
like oh no that person's a bully they
need their behavior needs to be
corrected it's like why speaking of uh
the people that get accused of being a
bully whether they are or not you
mentioned earlier the Trump machine is
falling apart yeah I think he's done
he's no way he can be present again and
I hate to make political predictions
because my ability to make them as bad I
don't I don't know I don't know I just
um
I'm here to report on political
conference so I'm kind of thinking about
what the future of the American right
wing
um I I think we're what I see in the
Trump movement to the extent I can
diagnose anything is a sort of
Jacksonian populism which has been
Australian and American politics what is
that that's a smart thing I don't know
yeah so you know Andrew Jackson
obviously uh Old Hickory
um obviously a colored a colored record
when it came to many things but
um there's an essay by Walter Russell
Mead that came out right when Trump got
elected was very good I wish I could
quote it from memory but basically the
idea behind Jacksonian populism is less
it's definitely not like Yankee New
England that's for sure it's obviously
More Southern orientation and it it it
it interprets the United States of
America as being less a creedal nation
less defined by a document and more you
know a nation in almost the European
sort of blood and soil sort of way
um and yeah it's a very populous
sentiment right it's kind of what was
behind the Tea Party Movement and the
Trump movement and it's just this
there's very strains in American
political side and occasionally they
kind of erupt right and um arguably
Trump was an eruption of that Jacksonian
populist and I think that strain exists
I mean Trump could get hit by a bus or
Keel over from a heart attack tomorrow
and that stream will still be there
right and the question is what expresses
it anyway and so um I think other
politicians can can look at people like
JD Vance Blake Masters DeSantis they're
all this kind of new generation of
politicians who are all very well
educated they all have a lot of Ivy
League degrees and what you would think
of as being sort of the elite background
and yet what I find interesting about
them is that they've turned their back
to some degree on that Elite background
right I mean you know Black Masters is
casting himself as the populist and he
you know he actually is from Arizona but
he's also you know Peterson's wealth
manager it's hardly it doesn't exactly
work out of Cabela's right um so yeah it
I don't know it's an interesting
politician I always think of Cabela's
because I I used to shop there more than
I do now but I was I always see it as
like it's like you know the United
States invited to either REI people and
Cabela's people here or Bass Pro Shop
people you're either one or the other
right and it's funny because you go into
those stores and they're supposed to be
outdoorsy stores but the products they
sell are completely different right and
REI is like mountain climbing super
expensive mountain climbing gear all
these fancy bikes and [ __ ] uh and that's
it and then you go to Cabela's and it's
like basically guns and boats and Camo
and camping equipment that's a lot less
fancy right and it's just a different
conception of nature of basically is
what it boils down to that's like great
framework I've never heard that before
but that is fantastic yeah you either
I'm actually I have both Rai and
Cabela's loyalty heart cards I'm one of
the few but I think most Americans have
one or the other in their wallet when
you think about uh this rise of like
populism and all this happening uh is it
again just a product of like the times
we live in and so people are being
opportunistic and seeing seeing it or do
you think that uh these folks with ivy
league degrees and all this stuff and
kind of like they're turning their back
on on maybe what got them to where they
are or whatever uh is it more so like
hey I grew up a certain way I see that
that's no longer here and like I have to
go be the one to kind of bring it back
or a Resurgence of some like past uh
component of American politics I think
that's right I think if you look at the
the family bios that people like to send
us and certainly Vance whose background
has been a whole book I'm not so sure
about Masters but there is a connection
to not that Elite Class and so I think
something rattling around in their heads
is part of that
um yeah I don't know I think I think the
a lot of what's going on this right is
kind of interesting in that you know the
left is sort of it's a bizarre in
version of European politics right in
European Politics the left is typically
kind of marxist and class system
orientation and the right tends to be
nationalist or even racist and
orientation in an extreme form in the
United States it's kind of a reverse
right the left is kind of weirdly
ethnically and racially obsessed and the
right I would say here is kind of a
class conscious movement right this
feeling of the middle class feeling
they're getting screwed by the upper
class right and the weird shaking out
like the left Coalition is basically you
know I would typify it as like people
who live off of doordash and the people
who deliver it to them right that's the
left Coalition people who shop at Whole
Foods and then people who get welfare
while those on the right tends to be
them in fact Peter Thiel one of the
quotes from his speech was you know the
Republicans are the party for the middle
class and the Democrats of their party
for everybody else right and so that's a
that's a strange split in American
politics and I think other thinkers of
you could cite people like um Burnham
Samuel Francis you know thinkers who
sort of framed at some point there would
be a middle American Revolt right that
the the American a classic revolt
against the it's sort of elite overseers
another book that I love is uh lashes
the Revolt of the elites he describes
how again there was this Elite Class
that would turn its back like back in
the day right hey you had more Regional
Elites every little state had its own
little Elites and then the sort of
consumption and lifestyle patterns of a
wealthy person and a middle class person
weren't that different in America like
everyone kind of shopped at Macy's and
it was this very middle class Mass
Market society and at some point
that's split and now you have an elite
that lives very very differently and
someone in Sanford and only in San
Francisco leaves very very differently
than my neighbors in the desert
Highlands outside of Reno right they're
kind of they're completely different
they live in totally different worlds
and that wasn't so much the case
um so I think that's causing that is at
its core what's causing this friction
and I think a lot of this new ride is a
rebellion against that Elite I think a
lot about uh what you're calling Elite
Rich versus like Redneck Rich yes right
growing up in North Carolina like there
was people who they had money but they
didn't have obviously degrees or
Ferraris they had a tricked out truck
with a lift and like the whole thing
which by the way can be expensive as
[ __ ] by the way like you see like in
Reno you see something that's an 80 000
like Jeep Rubicon like 60k base at least
and you've put at least 34k into it you
are not poor right right Redneck Rich
right right like like the whole idea of
Redneck Rich was basically like uh it
doesn't mean that you necessarily uh
don't have means it just means that you
express the wealth in a different way
and uh I specifically remember uh there
was kids that went to like local high
schools and stuff like that and there
was one area they would take these
trucks and they would go like mudding
right right and like you're like okay
cool got it like you have to have a
truck that can actually like go into the
mud and come out yeah all right because
if you just take a stock truck in there
like it's not coming out so uh to some
degree the country feels like the
Redneck Rich now have a voice with the
internet whereas maybe they didn't have
that before yeah yeah no I mean when I
say Elite people often kind of call
[ __ ] and what are you calling a lead
aren't you an elite this and that's like
there's something different about it
right like
you know some guy with like you know a
Dartmouth degree and 150 000 in student
loans who rise for an East Coast
literary thing and lives in Brooklyn
that are part of an Elite Class the guy
who has four car dealerships in
Asheville right and make 600k a year he
is not Elite even though their incomes
are very very different right
um yeah it's that's that's the Delta
it's what do you like when you look at
those two people like what do you think
makes up the difference and is it
obviously money is not one of the things
uh it could be a thing but but this
isn't the thing
um is it education is it like view of
the world like yeah view the world
politics
um you know the whole wokeness thing
which I don't typically like getting in
the middle of but um
yeah there's there's a difference in
Attitude there somehow you stared at the
world from the elite pedestal you know
you and I have lived inside this world
right and there's a set of sort of moral
assumptions about the world and you step
outside of it and there's a whole
different set of moral assumptions right
like the fact you've got the flag behind
you right like you wouldn't you probably
wouldn't do a zoom at a at a Fan Company
nowadays with like a flag behind you
right
um and uh yeah you wanna hear a crazy
story let's hear I've never said this
before okay let's hear it please say
this in the most unidentifiable way
possible uh there's somebody that we
work with uh who uh not a person an
organization okay uh and uh I made a
video and the fight was in the back and
they're like hey can you not do that
again and I thought I was ready to golf
like I had the Tweet locked and loaded I
was gonna [ __ ] go to town like this
was gonna be the Super Bowl it was like
draw the line in the sand like [ __ ] you
um and then it came out like the company
I don't know five percent of the sales
or something is in America and this
video is going to be put on a website
and they didn't want to think it was
only for America so like we have no
problem like if you want part of it to
have it or whatever but you just like
can you do it in a way so that like they
know that it's not just an American
thing like it's available globally and I
was like okay fine like let me you know
put the tweet in my drafts and keep it
warm in case I need it later oh I'm kind
of like put the gun back in the holster
but it's still loaded
um but but uh but but it was this like
weird thing like my first reaction when
I saw it was like no right and to your
point like I don't think if you work at
uh some of these companies you can do
that or somebody would say something
again you can Buck the trend whatever uh
stand up for what you think is right but
uh he might not work there very long uh
for the reasons whatever it does feel
like this weird thing where that is now
uh a contentious point yeah yeah I think
for the longest time
um the company Andrew I'm probably miss
pronouncing it um on their careers page
you used to have this massive American
flag in it and I theorized that it was
like basically nothing right it's
basically a filter and I think I
actually tweeted it at Palmer lucky and
he replied yeah that was intentional
there's somebody from Andrew said yeah
yeah that was an accident because they
have this enormous flag like I'm sure
you're seeing Patton right yeah comes
out with like a flag the size of a wall
yeah they had like that hanging in their
general area and then they had a photo
of that on their careers page yeah and I
think that was intentional that was the
garlic to the vampire so I I'm
fascinated by this whole like how do you
communicate uh implicitly
um especially when you start uh finding
the intersection of Technology politics
like uh Nationals like all these
different things that come together and
uh Sometimes the best way to understand
like what's happening in a MiraCosta
look elsewhere and so uh I saw a tweet I
think two days ago yesterday uh
zielinski from uh Ukraine he gave this
whole speech and uh it's translated and
you know who knows how accurate it is
but the general idea was like uh you
know [ __ ] you Russia uh if you give us
the choice between uh gas or you we will
take Gap uh no gas for you we will take
no gas if you give us the choice between
you and no water we will take no water
like all these things and like by the
way history proves that like at the end
we will have gas water electricity like
all stuff and we will be without you
right and and you listen to the speech
and the person was like oh he's going
full like Winston Churchill you're
sitting there like oh okay we have an
actor comedian who is now communicating
in a way that is obviously very
compelling to a lot of people he is
essentially going in front of the
American uh markets and saying like you
should invest in Ukraine in the Civil
War like all these things and he's doing
it with like a flag behind him he's
doing it uh Dressed very specifically
like you're meeting American politicians
they had time to put on their suits and
ties but you look like you literally
just got off the battlefield right and
like you're you're standing inside of
the government buildings in Kiev or
whatever
how do you like break that down you
literally went to Ukraine so you have
more inside a little bit of time there
yeah I spent a little bit time in the
western part of the country um because
at the early part of the war it was kind
of exciting and it felt like the image
we're having the United States was um
you know was obviously misinterpreted
and so okay uh a colleague of mine at
the Lincoln Network this DC think tank
that I'm a part of uh he's reported from
conflict zones in the past he's like hey
why don't we go I'll set up to fix it
and stuff you just come along and split
the class I'm like okay fine I'll ride
with you he ended up he ended up
eventually interviewing zelenski for
Wired Magazine and going all the way to
Keith
um I had to go do a podcast of all
things so I had to go do broken it was
kind of funny I was I was literally Joe
Rogan pulls you out of I know I was I
was in I was in the Viv in Western
Ukraine with like a star link hanging
out of my window like like texting the
booker guy and I'm like dude like I hate
to break it to you but I'm like actually
going to where is it like it's gonna be
hard for me to get back in time can we
just like Zoom it in and it might be
kind of cool because I'm like zooming
from you and he's like no you have to
physically be here like we can
reschedule but it'll be months ahead so
like you decide I'm like [ __ ] and so I'm
like
and spend the three or four days it took
till I get back and again I wasn't that
I wasn't that deep into it at all but
it's weird like
um I mean you served right so you yeah
yeah and so you know how your risk
threshold kind of changes it's like it's
kind of scary when I was like humping my
bag with like body armor and the
starlink and [ __ ] across the because you
can't take cars across the border so
you're literally walking across the
border into like this unknown future I'm
like man Antonio walked into war zone no
starlink on his back right now well it
was [ __ ] scary and it was weird too
because like the Border checkpoint
there's like this line that stretched
for miles of refugees to get out and
you're like walking alone and they're
like staring at you like are you [ __ ]
crazy like what are you doing walking in
that direction bro I'm like and like
walking across like this this feels
really dumb like I don't know what I'm
doing was it just you two or yeah I
always said no it's just this too yeah
it was me no like when you're crossing
the border there's lit nobody going in
oh no no
um you would see legionnaires at the
time they were recruiting the Foreign
Legion and then you would see other
media and so you'd see other press with
their bulletproof vest with the Press
tag on it and you'd see young healthy
men who had kit from various camo
patterns who were clearly from different
militaries who were showing up and yeah
and there's nobody else the the um the
the few people that I've seen go uh
their former US military defense
contractors whatever uh when they're
there I'm like looking around I'm like
man that looks kind of crazy like you
got a bunch of people with guns and kits
and they're like running around
everything and then uh you see the media
which obviously uh when I was in Iraq
they were there uh very different time
like it was kind of like hey getting the
vehicle shut up and like you know if you
put us in danger like we're gonna
[ __ ] freak out
um but here like there's like walking
down the street and I don't know it just
seems kind of different
well it was I mean it's a country it's a
country something I'd never experienced
before I expect none of a severe
experience it's a country in Total War
right it's a country it's a European
nation that has gotten invaded and
social order is kind of not totally
broken down in an archive way but but
most of society is either trying to get
out women so men couldn't get out so it
was like if you're if you're at the
Polish border it's just literally like
women in like a woman with like two kids
and a little cat in the bag and a little
rolly bag like basically all they have
in the clothes in their back just like
walking across the border to another
like that's it and you just see like
this endless stream of such people and
what's going on in the other side of the
Border because I think a lot of people
don't realize this like once they get
over there are they meeting like family
and friends are there just like right
now they're trying to help them some are
having like tier for reunions but
usually it's amazing I mean it's a
little dated now I'm sure it's quiet now
compared to what it used to be but there
was enormous number of like Jose Andres
the Spanish Chef his world Central
kitchens I think it's called was all
over the place
I interviewed just a random polish woman
from the village he's like oh yeah the
refugees are coming so like she had this
big thing of soup that she was doing her
best to help yeah yeah so Europe really
just mustered in a huge way I mean every
train station in Poland became a refugee
camp basically because they're all like
the Warsaw train station was totally
taken over by refugees you know it was
it was literally millions of refugees
like a quarter of the Ukrainian
population fled
um so it was uh it was a chaotic
situation then you got on the inside and
there's again more refugees coming out
but then also men and material going
east right and then all Society like
there's a scene there it was in on a
Sunday a bunch of high school kids like
having fun joshing like you think
they're having babies like no they're
filling sandbags and pulling the
sandbags around statue because they
thought airstrikes were happening and
there were a few airstrikes and lived
later and so they you know and they're
shuddering everything it's just like
those scenes you see in black and white
from World War II was kind of the vibe
right yeah even though this is far away
from the front lines to be clear
um yeah that was the feeling in it and
that's when I kind of real it's like man
I don't know like I think the Russian's
gonna have a hard time winning because
everyone was so mobilized they would
literally punctuate said you know
sentences with we will win and like
these steely-eyed gazes and everyone
kind of mobilize like I don't know man
Ukraine's a big place so when I saw this
happening one of the first things I
thought about was uh God forbid that
this happened in the United States
somehow somebody figured it out and they
invaded the United States yeah would we
have the same response and I don't think
we would I think well I think uh I might
show my political scripts I I think I
think you would have that I think you
would have the response you think so
I think it wouldn't be the people you'd
expect
um okay interesting yeah this is this is
where the Redneck Side of Me comes out I
think uh I think the people you see at
shooting ranges in California uh who
tend to those guys are going to the
Sierra and Red Dawn the whole [ __ ]
thing I think the people you know a lot
of people the urban dwellers absolutely
would not and they would just go along
with whatever the regime is
um yeah I think um you know you've
probably gone shoot in California back
in the day and it's you know mostly
world whites a lot of Asians a lot of
Hispanics like those guys would hole up
and like smuggle arms around and like
muster for a militia and a lot of people
would just get on the first plane and
get the [ __ ] out yeah yeah yeah it's um
it's fascinating because if you really
think about uh Ukraine like again this
is a story's oldest time but like you're
there you've got your family you've got
a business you're running whatever and
next thing you know like literally your
family's refugees right it happens in a
matter of days uh what was the most
surprising thing that you felt like you
saw on the ground that maybe wasn't
being told in America or was like being
misrepresented uh in America I guess I
think the level of the level of
mobilization and sort of national
solidarity that there was right I knew
nothing about you I still don't know
very much about Ukraine don't speak any
Eastern European or Slavic languages so
to me it was a vastly foreign country
and I guess you know once I was there I
did start reading about it Ukrainian
nationalism has been a thing it's had
very much a checkered past
um as as many movements did during World
War II
um but there's been this Ukrainian
national movement for a couple centuries
now and it's odd that you know
nationalism we think of countries as
having existed forever because like
France has existed forever but it's it's
politics has been very different Spain
has existed forever but it's politics
has been very different and the
emergence what we now call the nation
state with sort of a secular mostly
secular administrative state with a
notion of national unity and you're a
citizen of a certain country rather than
an Empire or a dynasty that's kind of a
novelty right and that that struck all
of Europe the United States is one of
the great experiments in in in
nation-state creation
um but a lot of countries didn't get
their own Nation for a while right the
polls the Czechs the the serbians the
slovaks ETC and somehow the ukrainians
never got theirs either and somehow
we're seeing the fruition of this
nationalist movement I think if you talk
to ukrainians a lot of things changed
um with the protests against the
previous what was considered a Russian
stooge
um and it's it's odd to see well I'll go
[ __ ] angry and crazy and yelling and
screaming our podcast if you go that
direction there's a lot of a lot of
American commenters particularly on the
right who were remarkably sympathetic to
Putin and thought the ukrainians should
just roll over and who have frankly shut
the [ __ ] up about the war since then
since they got it so completely wrong
clearly but um you know who wanted to
just deny the fact or claim that the
2014 was like a CIA office like dude
look at the photos there's like a
million ukrainians in that protest like
the CIA this actor budget must have been
pretty goddamn lit if you claim this is
a CIA I'm just like no like I hate to
break and Americans often have this
attitude like they think everything is a
projection of their own domestic
political Neurosis right like if the CIA
lifts a little finger oh then like a
million person Riot happens and keeps
like dude if only like no that's not how
it actually works they have their own
political processes they have their own
political crises and they have their own
thoughts and Views about the world that
don't line up with American domestic
political priorities that's just the
reality of it if you want to understand
that world you have to get out of your
American attitude understand and see the
world from their perspective right and
if you talk to them it's like dude we've
had democracy for whatever seven or
eight years we're not giving it up now
we're not going to be under Putin's heel
that's it I will I will die for this
country right and that yeah and that's
that's something that I think caught
everyone by surprise
um finally a friend of mine I want name
names whatever he was a Mormon
missionary to Ukraine he was there
before the previous Russian invasion and
the war in the East and he was surprised
at how much Ukrainian nationalism
resilience there was so a lot of it
clearly was a very recent phenomenon but
I think you know zielinski not leaving
everyone you know he's supremely popular
there I think zelenski is this whole
business of like I don't need to write I
need ammo right I think that rallied a
nation in a big way and um it was some
baller [ __ ] I was I think I think yeah I
think it's some baller [ __ ] yeah the
other piece that I saw a lot of people
talking about is like dude what are you
talking about like he's acting like you
know people are dropping bombs on his
City and like he's like literally like
uh running from uh bunker to Bunker like
he's you know got politicians coming to
visit him he's in this or whatever I was
like I don't think that uh this was like
Hey I'm going to die if I stay or not it
was the symbol of like we're not we're
not running we're gonna fight and to
some degree like the morale of the
country seemed to shift and I think that
uh part of it also was like he seems to
very well understand American culture
and like how to kind of pull the strings
because when he said that specific line
it felt like America was like [ __ ] yeah
that guy sounds awesome right right oh
his marketing is incredible which is a
good thing right every everywhere has
propaganda right that's part of the war
I mean America did in World War II and
so that's definitely part of it but I I
would clarify that I mean he wasn't
bunkers hiding from bombs in the early
part of the war Kiev was encircled right
the thought that he would survive you
know Wagner mercenaries were dispatch
which murder him like I mean nowadays
yes you're right I mean Vitality can
just go to the key of blockchain thing
and it's not that hard to get to but
that was not the case in early March
when things were much more sort of
loosey-goosey so and when that happened
like what do you think was the big shift
was it literally that they've pushed the
forces back I know now we have kind of
an advance that's happening that
everyone uh believes it has a lot of
momentum to it but uh I I don't think
people quite understand
um uh it feels like the story in America
has been Russia has tried to invade
they've had some successes but they're
running into resistance and like that's
the story not so much that like no maybe
actually they're like losing ground now
there's this Advanced now there's like
almost a a a counter punch that's
occurring and like if we know anything
about military history like that's
usually if you can keep that momentum
like that's how you end up Victorious
it's not so much like uh hey we resist
in the beginning it's no we resist and
then we counter punch and that seems to
be happening now this episode is brought
to you by eight sleep good sleep is a
game changer and the eight sleep pod is
the best sleep machine I sleep on it
every single night a great night of
sleep allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod 3 you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees Fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself in each sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eatsleep.com pump not only do I sleep on
it every night it literally changed my
life and I begged the founders to let me
invest in the company hsleep.com go get
yourself an eight-sleep pod and get a
better night of sleep yeah I mean I
think yeah the big news there is
obviously that the I think the question
was can the ukrainians go on the
offensive and recapture territory it's
one thing to actually defend territories
the other thing to actually take
territory
um and yeah I think rolling back the
Russians from Buca 20 did you ever work
with uh Dwight no you didn't he probably
left Dwight Crowe Facebook I did yeah
yeah so I ran into him like a week ago
at South Park Commons in South Park okay
last night talk to him was through a
starling connection dude that guy was
actually in the [ __ ] he was serving
um I never published an interview with
him I probably should he was serving in
a volunteer ambulance crew on the front
lines actually shut up no he absolutely
he would do that he he would do that and
he did that like I I saw the video I did
he was like losing he was in a hospital
in the front lines he'd go out volunteer
basis and go pull the civilian dead
bodies from from the or the injured from
the front lines I wish we were having
this conversation not on air but uh he
always struck me as the type of guy who
like he's gonna live life right yeah and
uh the one thing I remember about Dwight
is uh uh a theme posted on Facebook he
like went declined maybe Mount
Kilimanjaro or something and Everest
like a month ago or okay yeah so like he
he'd been climbing these things or
whatever I think it was Kilimanjaro when
he did it and he was like I got to the
top and I couldn't [ __ ] breathe and I
like crawled my way to the science I was
gonna get this [ __ ] photo and he had
like a selfie or whatever and I remember
just being like yep that checks out like
that is the type of person he is so to
hear this is not shocking oh yeah you
know I should go back to him we should
probably publish that interview
um but yeah yeah no he was he was on the
front lines and then um he survived
there he came back and um but yeah I
know getting back to the Ukraine thing
yeah I mean the business of being on the
offensive while they reclaim territory
will they take Odessa you know there's a
lot of questions right because it's
clear that
attitudes in the Ukraine have hardened
like they were willing to compromise and
more or less give up much of the Crimea
to the Russians
um but that's no longer true and part of
their National conception is actually
coming at all back um we'll see
um I mean I you know I I have no
obviously no insight to what they're
actually thinking but I have to imagine
that they understand that European
resolve might waiver given their energy
costs Europe's going to freeze this
winter it does not look well
um I think I retweeted a pretty harsh
joke that said um you know what did the
British use to um
to uh light their homes for candles
electricity right there that's like oh
um I take no joy in that joke by the way
but it is it's one of these jokes that
like reveals the greater truth yes like
ooh so and he must understand that
resolve for the war has to waver in
European politics given the the
privations the the story that uh from
Russia and again I want to be careful I
don't get all this uh data points wrong
because everyone in the comments will
definitely let us know uh but
um it does feel like uh there's this
thing like there's like been like eight
Russian uh energy Executives oil
Executives whatever who have
mysteriously gone missing died whatever
uh and then we get pipeline shut down
and yeah okay we're not turning it back
on like there's all this stuff going on
and I think that Americans are like oh
that [ __ ] that like we thought actually
happens like that does happen like you
know I mean you can kind of almost see
like Oh I thought that was just like in
history or I thought that was like in uh
fiction books like that's like real
stuff and I've talked to a couple
friends and they're like
oh and I'm like yeah it's a [ __ ] War
like they're literally trying to kill
each other right and and to some degree
I think America got so uh blunted to
like the realities of War because we
were at War for 20 years and it was just
kind of like this thing that happens
every once in a while there's like a
news story or whatever but like if
you're you know 18 19 years old like you
did not live a single day without
America at war in the Middle East right
now America well technically is not
fighting in the War uh well they are
it's a proxy worth
how many millions have you said Ukraine
you something about me well the the
thing that I saw which uh just blew my
mind is like hey we have billions of
dollars for uh Ukraine to fight a war
but we don't have enough money to solve
the Water Crisis in Jackson Mississippi
right and so like a little bit of like
hey why are we so worried about all
these other problems around the world uh
uh which uh is Up For Debate but it does
feel like America to some degree like
the initial invasion was a big moment
and then like we just go back to like
kind of being blunted to the realities
of it yeah right because you're right
because that United States has been
continuous like war in fact it's
involved in what six or seven different
regions at least right now and nobody
thinks about it because he's basically
Outsource it to a small amount already
people since we have a professional Army
and there's no conscription and I think
it creates this level of media cynicism
about war that it literally is like the
current thing like one of the things
that most piss me off about the Ukraine
is like oh I don't see Ukraine in my
feet I guess it's the current thing yeah
cause a [ __ ] shooting war is just a
media cycle to you is that is that what
you think it is it's like no it's a
little bit more than that and by the way
no the word's not over we're still
giving them billions there's so people
died there's still this whole thing
going on just because you don't see it
in your feed it's not it doesn't mean
it's not real
um and so
yeah I mean but of course the media side
of it does matter and zelenski
understands that which is why he's
leading the propaganda where that he is
um you mentioned uh that a big part of
this was like ukrainians like I'll die
from my country right uh you also wrote
a piece uh would you die for the Dow oh
yeah right uh and uh down slowly snarky
headlines but literally being
decentralized autonomous organization
and it was somewhat of a a review
summary critique whatever you want to
call it of uh Balaji srinivas since the
network state so talk a little bit about
uh you know the United States Ukraine
Russia yeah like now there's this new
idea of like let's go create like cities
in the cloud right which I think uh
Belushi's done a great job of
articulating and kind of laying out uh
what did you kind of take away from that
yeah that was a review of biology's
network State and also the vitalik's
response the Metallica were a very long
piece about it as well and I think it's
a fascinating concept and I recommend
reading the book actually I also
interviewed him on my um on my podcast
the pull request you can get an Apple
podcast I had a long conversation with
budgie about it um and to be clear you
know Balaji and I don't really disagree
at some fundamental level he understands
so let me just frame what the problem is
and then what the debate became so
abolish's idea I mean there's a lot of
biology in there if you know Balaji I'm
sure you've had a lot of interesting
conversations as I've had
um with Balaji he's an interesting
character so like the first half is like
pure like balaji's brain and view of the
world which is fascinating there's
literally like seven links in one
sentence like very which is why we all
love him okay no he's amazing he's
amazing the guy I don't know how he
manages all the tabs but he's gotta have
some he blocks it has some sort of tab
management system that none of us have
yet figured out I mean you're right his
brain has 200 open tabs at all times
that's the reality and the CPU still
runs somehow my MacBook Pro can handle
it but blodges brain can
um yeah and then at the end I wish he
had spent he's he's had you can find it
online by the way it's a beautiful
website online and he's added chapters
to it but in the original book he gets
into what he called the network State
and the idea here is that
um imagine a sort of Federated I mean in
the same way that like
I I made this comment in my critiques
like imagine bellagistan let's just give
it a name existed right and we're the
largestanis right and we literally just
move from three or four neighborhoods in
San Francisco to the same three or four
neighborhoods in Miami the same in New
York and let's say there's actual
borders passports the whole deal would
we even notice it's like no because we'd
never cross the border we would
literally just fly from one to the other
and so I think biology is absolutely
right that like de facto this is it's
already the case that there's a self
sort of selecting set of people who live
in this weird disembodied somewhat Elite
realm to be honest that fly between
these various cities and live a
different life and they have much more
in common than they do with even people
like country they're right down the
street right
um and some could say that's a bad thing
and maybe it is
um I personally one of the things one of
the weirdest things I think that's
happened in 200 years and you and I are
probably roughly the same age so you
probably remember the analog era a
little bit right it's like remember
getting letters right like information
used to move as fast as like physical
objects would move and now they don't
information is uncoupled from from
physical movement which means who you
are what you think what you believe is
uncoupled from your surroundings and
that means the little colored squares in
the map called Miami Florida State of
Florida United America are uncoupled
from what who you think believe talk
with Etc and I think that's a major
change and somehow a lot of the getting
back to the whole DeSantis versus Newsom
war and everyone moving different states
like that's
I think biology called it defragmenting
a disc like remember back in the in the
in the Dos days and or even current
Windows like the memories written all
over and then at some point you've got
to take all the apps memory and take it
to one place because it gets too
inefficient he's like yeah the network
state is basically defragmenting people
and putting all the people that actually
have common values and are willing to
live under the same rules in the same
physical place because the physical so
to be clear this is not transhumanism
this is not VR this is not uploading
your brain it's like no no no we need
like physical boots on the ground so to
speak place to live seat at the U.N laws
people who take out the garbage but for
a self you know sort of selecting set of
people
um that's his thesis and you know again
like I said like I'm I'm partial to it
because I think the political crisis
that he highlights is very real
um the question is would you die for the
Dow right because it not that everything
is [ __ ] war on fighting these days
obviously very little of life is but at
some level you have to say even if it's
not like I will die for the die it's
like I will raise my children inside
this environment right that's the real
bet you make and are people actually
going to do that because you know you
probably know the same people dried into
practice there's a lot of you know the
Prosper people like all very interesting
I'm like super pro makers and Builders
and doing cool new stuff I don't want to
ding them at all but I do Wonder it's
like well you need some oomph there and
it's funny I I like joke tweeted a few
months ago a lot of this Charter Nation
business is like Zionism without Judaism
right and then like literally just
yesterday Ebola she said oh no no I
wasn't inspired by Neil Stevens and I
was inspired by Theodore herzl the
founder of modern Zionism right and it's
true right and the design for those who
aren't familiar with Zionism or with
Judaism for that matter right a lot of
Zionism getting back to the Nash all
these nationalist movements sprung up in
late 19th century right including a lot
of the Ukrainian uh nationalist movement
and in the case of the Jewish one it's a
little strange because it's not like oh
the ground we sit on should become a
country rather than the austro-hungarian
Empire it's like well we're not even on
the ground but we are people because
we've been living in exile for almost
2000 years and therefore we should move
somewhere else and before the current
location of Israel was the thing there
was plans of Argentina Uganda all sorts
of places where the Jews had moved to
um but there was always this feeling of
like yeah the Dao so to speak was the
feeling of Jewish identity right and
there was you know for again almost 2000
years drummed into their heads this
feeling of exilic Despair right
um some of it stemming from previous
Exiles but like the Israeli National
Anthem
um you know says looking to the east
towards Zion which Echoes the psalm
which reflects the Jews being exiled to
Babylon you know in 500 BC and so
there's this feeling of of of of of
and it's odd because the land that they
weren't even a part of like nobody had
been a part of for generations and so
it's like that feeling of like belief
does that exist for these Charter
Nations and do you even need it maybe
you don't I've talked to some of the
prospera people which is this thing in
um Honduras that's like a special
economic zone they're like you know you
don't really need a whole new country
you just need like special economic
terms and the ability to move there and
that's all you need so I've talked about
a lot of people as well uh and when you
think it's hilarious that we're talking
about Charter Nation business right uh
which is an important part of it as well
uh because you do need to make it
sustainable
um and these I think I've gotten a lot
of uh attention because they are like
planning a flight on the ground like
we're going to create a special
economics on we're going to create a
whole new city or a country or whatever
but like there's also kind of watered
down versions I think uh uh there was
the mountain uh Powder Mountain or
whatever that uh a whole group of people
they went bought a mountain they started
cut up all the the land they were
selling these pieces or plots or
whatever uh they were gonna like build
like biscuit neighborhood right like if
you kind of think of like the most
watered down version is like Hey we're
gonna go create a neighborhood you can
also go try to create a new nation but
what I do think we've like seen an
example of this kind of play out in
front of our eyes which is Miami yeah
which it actually had almost nothing to
do with like the physical uh
infrastructure and all this like yes
there were some things that were
advantageous but I think if you were to
ask some of the people who moved here
first uh there was like no like we just
like there's 300 people and if we could
get those 300 people wouldn't even like
you it was like somebody like you to
fill this seat and we get 300 of them
then like we have momentum we have like
a nucleus and like We're Off to the
Races and it is a higher probability of
like escape velocity and like this will
be a thing that will stay around for a
long time it feels like most of the
other folks who are trying these like
new nation things it's more about the
like physical location it's more about
like what are the rules than like just
the people and and I don't know if
you've thought at all about that in
terms of like pros or cons between the
difference I mean I've thought about
Miami right Miami is almost its own
little sort of city state it feels weird
like for those who don't spend time here
you know not to put to find a point on
it but it feels very different than like
Fort Lauderdale right Fort Lauderdale
was great nice airport to fly out of but
you there's some sort of Border you
cross between data and Broward County
when you go north and this is not like
Orlando right it's nothing wrong with
Orlando but it's different and like I
don't know it in in my ideal World there
would be some like Maritime Republic of
Miami and mayor Suarez is Doja and it's
like it's like it's it's like the
northern Italian city-states and it's
just like this weird little place with
its own laws and you know I don't know
it'd be kind of cool frankly I think we
need more of those experiments like I
you know a lot of these people like to
practice people like dude why don't you
just like why don't you just take over a
county in Florida and just convince the
scientists now that he's like you know
smacked around Disney convince him to
give you some countries or like even
these retirement communities like The
Villages right like you know they have
like 200 000 people they have like their
own police force it's like a whole city
in there yeah it's like you know in
Florida you can what is the island uh
there's um Fisher Island is it Fisher
Island no there's uh uh uh Indian Creek
right it's like super wealthy right oh
yeah and I've never been there and uh
it's got like a golf course on it
there's like 30 40 50 homes whatever it
is and they have like a 13-person police
force and they Patrol not by only land
but also by sea and they have like a
boat and like like the whole thing and
it's like of course you know I think uh
uh Jared Kushner and uh Ivanka Trump
bought a place there and there's all
these types of people whatever but
you're like okay cool it's not 200 000
people but it's like 50 homes and like
again they don't have special laws but
they sure as hell have an army that'll
show up if you try to like you know you
try to get on the island right and so
like yeah what is the difference between
40 homes and you know 100 000 homes like
I don't know it's not that big a
difference yeah yeah but yeah but we
should do these experiments I think it'd
be cool what do you think is stopping it
or what are the obstacles is it just
like that sounds insane to the average
person uh I think people have I don't
know I mean or it takes hard work and
somebody has to believe to be the first
to like right right there has to be a
sort of generative faith in some future
community that you're trying to they're
either supposed to be greed or faith and
those are the two driving things like
you have to believe in some national you
know Vision or just say you know I'm
sick of taxes and these [ __ ] up laws
I'm gonna like make common cause with
these 500 other rich people and do this
thing right
um yeah that's that's what I would say
the uh the thing it also jumps to mind
is I remember uh was it Clive Bundy
remember in uh was it uh Nevada or Utah
it's like Oregon the malware thing
though the like those guys I think that
was uh uh after the original standoff
but uh again I don't want to get all the
details wrong but uh essentially I think
his name's Clive Bundy he's got like a
huge you know Geographic uh area uh I'll
call it a farmer Ranch but like
basically a city right in terms of size
and uh the federal government came and
was like you know imminent domain like
we're taking some of this or whatever
and he like called his buddies I guess
and they like showed up with horses and
guns and and it was like everyone does
and I remember seeing on the news like
you're like holy [ __ ] like these are
like ranchers and like that looks like a
SWAT sniper set up on the highway like
you know with a scope and you're just
like is this you know the okay Corral
like what is going on here
I don't think that anyone generally in
the American public is like that's what
I'm willing to go do to like set up a
new city but like it does become
interesting if you go and you get a
governor or some sort of uh special
treatment and they say Hey you can try
the experiment in this location I think
there's a lot of people who would say
yeah I'll opt into that yeah yeah yeah I
mean particularly in the west there's so
many open spaces so where my house is is
in Story County outside of Reno which is
where Virginia City is which used to be
like the Gold Rush town and there's uh I
forget his name um oh it's a guy who
founded jet.com one is e-commerce yeah
yeah I think you brought up a city right
yeah he turns up a city and which by the
way man good luck to him because I live
in the high desert it is a harsh it gets
you're gonna freeze your ass off in the
winter and it gets hot as hell in the
summer and it's a very harsh environment
there is much water and it's hard to
live out there but
um yeah I mean you you know you can buy
tens of thousands of acres for not much
money in what in the western Americas
and if you can convince people to move
there
um we'll see but again I think and again
getting back to the Balaji conversation
he freely concedes that there needs to
be a moral case made for the state and
the weird thing that I've always tried
to push biology and it's like dude but
what is the moral case tell me what is
the moral case for your network State
and he kind of talks around it doesn't
you know I think he just doesn't see
himself as that person maybe providing
the moral codes what do you think it
should be
I don't know man it's
I don't know I wrote this piece called
uh side thing on my experience in
Judaism I had this whole Judaism
religious thing
um I think there's kind of like a
god-shaped hole at the heart of a lot of
secular liberalism by God don't
necessarily mean like you know guy with
a beard in the sky I just mean some
notion of transcendent good to you know
I think it was um
um I think it was not Walter Benjamin uh
who's the other guy anyhow um William
James the uh varieties of religious
experience who said you know the at its
core religious sentiment is the belief
that there's some sort of moral order
towards which we should be striving
right that there's some unseen moral
good that we should arrange human
Affairs according to right and if you
frame it that way everything is religion
right literally the traffic laws outside
that say I can't park for longer than
three hours are a form of religion
because there's some greater parking
good right that again empirically
doesn't exist there is no good right
there's no good in the microscope we
invent these things right and so how how
do you invent a moral good that says yes
we should have this like modern day
Hanseatic leagues of Federated crypto
cities governed by tokens I don't know
how do you make that case it might just
be a capitalist case of like hey there's
lower taxes things work better move here
I don't know what what's funny is uh the
intersection of religion in new cities
uh I've always thought that actually the
better way to try to do this in the
United States I don't think
internationally uh this uh holds up but
in the United States it's actually to
take one of the pseudo-religions uh take
ESG and basically use that which we do
see companies like theater's one called
cul-de-sac which is like Hey we're going
to build a city but like there's no uh
streets for cars it's like walkable only
there's no cars allowed like all this
stuff and like actually if you went to
somebody in the government and was like
uh we're anarchists we're gonna like
take down you know whatever we're gonna
build our own thing or even a watered
down version of like we're building our
own City with our own laws and taxes
they're like we're gonna put you on a
list somewhere and like we're gonna
watch you guys and like that's not
allowed but if you show up you're like
Hey we're gonna build a new city and uh
no cars are allowed they're like oh
great how much money do you need like
what land do you want you know and like
there's a conversation
what's the difference like moral good no
cars uh it does feel like there's like
this whole world carbon zero is the new
moral good man that is the the new moral
good food so it's we should be striving
there are people who are uh are headed
that way
um another thing that's interesting to
me is uh this new world uh is so you
take like uh Network Stakes or whatever
uh a lot of times there are critiques on
the old world uh but we do see in the
technology world like it seems that some
of the new world is just recreating
problems of the old world so if you look
uh Dallas cryptos one by the way that's
exactly where we're going so Dao's uh
somebody recently pitched me uh on this
like Dow thing and I was like I don't
know like what what is your Dow got
that's so special and he's like well let
me explain one of the problems in Dao's
is that uh there's a lot of people and
there's no like structure and so nobody
really knows what anyone's working on
and there's like no strategy and all
stuff so we have this concept uh we're
going to create sub-dos inside of the
Dow and I was like what do you mean and
they were like well like all the product
people are going to be in one sub data
to work on products and marketing and I
was like so divisions in a company and
like again I get it there's tons and
tons of people out there and one
anecdote does not necessarily uh kind of
sentence all of them to like this is
stupid
but I literally was like this like
where's the hidden camera like this has
got to be a joke that like you're
literally describing a corporation to me
just using Dao instead and I think that
the critics of the uh broad crypto
industry uh would say like hey that's
just like one example like there's a
hundred others of just recreating the
problems or recreating some of these
things
how do you think through like some of
the the naiveness or like the stupidity
that goes well I wouldn't call it
somebody but um yeah some of it is
stupid some of it is not some of it
harsh words
oh come on by the way I've talked to
people and been like that sounds kind of
crazy like yeah we know it's stupid but
right so like it can be a lovable thing
as well I mean I think the fact that
like for example Defy is speed running a
lot of the problems of like
conventional 19th and 20th Century
Finance is probably a good sign in a way
it's like you've had Bank runs you've
had a speculative bubbles like oh like
the entire history of the stock market
basically the past Century and a half
it's like yeah I mean it's kind of dumb
to be stepping on the exact same
landmines that the previous world did
ideally you could kind of avoid that
part of what my company hopes to do is
like okay let's not do the stupidity of
web 2 attribution again like let's just
get to the real answer
um on the other hand I don't know man
yeah look I so I just got to this party
so to speak so it's hard for me to sit
here in judgment but it does strike me
that there's a lot of interesting energy
and Innovation going on in web3 and
crypto and then a lot of things that are
like super naive and like whoa you've
never had like a real job before have
you you've never been inside like a real
tech company and seen how the sausage is
made have you
um and again that's both good and bad
right that can mean that you can invent
new stuff and like yeah you don't give a
[ __ ] how it was built before on the
other hand it's like you invented an
organization chart
it is true but but I think it's
important also it can be a amazing thing
because you're gonna get people with new
ideas who frankly don't know that they
shouldn't try something or whatever and
like this yeah but then also the other
side is the the crazy stuff yeah I mean
specifically in my example just to cut
to it right so just raise money I guess
this is my I've said it before but
whatever
um raise money for a company that's uh
in web 3 attribution and user
acquisition and for those who don't know
what the means a lot of people want
three down I've had to explain it it's
like you know you do a token drop what's
the ROI on that was it worth was it
let's just go to the web tuber explain
kind of like how uh these web 2
companies yeah Facebook's twitters
Googles all these stuff like many people
I think outside of the tech industry
will be like oh Facebook's amazing like
uh I get on their software I connect
with people and like they don't realize
like no literally somebody is watching
did you click or not what color is the
button like uh when I was at Facebook I
remember uh the create page button on
Facebook if you go assuming it's still
there uh is green every other button on
Facebook's blue but that one's [ __ ]
green right and people there was a huge
debate like increased click through rate
10 yeah can we make it green like does
it violate our design standards like all
this stuff and like guess what we showed
up and we were like look at the click
through right and like here's day night
people were like well [ __ ] the design
standard like make that [ __ ] green
because that's the top of the funnel to
make money right and so like explain a
little bit as like attribution like how
some of this stuff happens in the in the
old world right and so just be clear
when Facebook is watching it's not Zuck
sitting like literally sitting there
laughing at the at the DM to your
girlfriend just because people's team
has like yes zaka's sitting there and
listening to what you're saying right
now and making a joke at your expense
it's like obviously it's it's much more
high level it's aggregated there's no
individual much of anything going on
yeah so so
the funnel you said a lot there actually
right so like what is the funnel so the
final obviously white on top narrow at
the bottom and it's the central metaphor
for like everything in almost everything
in web 2 in marketing right same from a
very mercenary point of view every
company is actually a marketing company
with like a little side hustle like a
game company is actually a mark and this
is actually true most game companies are
actually marketing companies that happen
to just create games to have a thing to
sell and how they navigate that funnel
what does it mean to navigate The Funnel
so what's at the top of the funnel top
of the funnel is things like Facebook
posts Instagram posts tweets
random browsing on the internet the very
high level touch surface of of your
media experience I mean in the real
world it's seeing Billboards listening
to this podcast whatever it is right
then you go further into the funnel
right you've responded to some call to
action you've clicked on the thing
you've installed an app right CTA to use
the the term of art
um you install the app right so you're
kind of mid funnel like you might
convert right note the religious
language when you buy a thing you
convert it's like Mormons like trying to
save your soul right this is capitalism
is Transcendence speaking of organizing
principles that's that's what we've
gotten to the only thing we believe is
capitalism
um and then you get deeper into the
funnel you're in the app you upgrade to
the paid plan you buy the nft you do
whatever it is kaching the cash register
goes off how do you join all that [ __ ]
right because I've mentioned like three
or four different platforms or more than
that that it's happening how does the
person you running the pages team or
whatever at Facebook or me with the
exchange or like how do you or somebody
inside a defy exchange now how does how
do you actually think how do I figure
all that out that's it and what they're
trying to do is they're trying to
understand okay we reached at the very
top of the funnel somebody somewhere saw
something about us and that was a
million people how many of those million
people then went to the like uh website
then how many of the website clicked the
button and then how many people bought
and can we then start to tweak well if a
million people saw it and only 40 came
through can we get it to 50 60 and
actually move the metrics right so those
are the high level analytics so that and
then so there's a lot going and then
there's like a compute step which is
like who do we give credit for the for
the conversion and I had like in my
pitch deck I had like a joke apocryphal
quote actually from Stalin that said you
know who votes in an election doesn't
matter who counts the votes matters
right and an attribution it's also true
dangerous in today's day and age well
yeah you know who clicks and where kind
of doesn't matter who counts the clicks
is what matters right so I always cite
the example I also had to slide in the
deck by the way and Jason callicanus who
we all know and love not really but um
no we do we do love them despite his
many personality flaws
um I love you Jason you can come on
anytime and you and Antonio I'll gladly
sit here and just shut up and let you
guys talk
he's gonna come and give you a hug and
then make a tweet at your expense like I
did with palmer but anyhow
um
um in any case um I I just just myself
just know for a second that uh uh Jason
I know he's in pain because I've seen
him tweet like multiple times now uh I
don't know if you've seen the all-in uh
podcast which is excellently done they
uh they continue just to crank out great
content uh but now there's been a couple
of times where either chamoth or David
sax has worn something on the show so
like a hat or I think one of them had
like a sweater and these are like
high-end Brands okay and uh because the
all-in podcast audience is insane they
go and they start buying that thing and
they're like selling out like literally
there's like some random Elite sweater
that like is sold out now if you tell me
David's actually wearing like a Louis
Vuitton baseball cap with the symbols
and [ __ ] on it like something like that
I forget what the brand was and like the
hats sold out know what to find it and
so of course like somebody goes and they
screenshot it and they're like hey you
know all in uh folks uh you guys are
like you know uh driving all these sales
and she's just like are you kidding me
we created this podcast and now we can't
monetize it but yeah we're like driving
sales to all this other [ __ ] and so he
is in pain right now even though they
are having the success of the podcast
the fact that they won't let them
monetize it is uh him excruciatingly uh
sitting there saying like this is a
missed opportunity I mean that's such a
weird thing I have actually spoken at
the all in Summit actually I debated
then Greenwald in Ukraine at their thing
and what an odd bunch of characters
I love it I listen every week and I
think that uh uh it is uh exactly the
thing that was missing for a lot of
people it's like they're like okay like
what are like some of the people who are
not media people uh talking about and
most of the time people have tried to
create that like there's no trust so
then nobody says anything interesting
these guys are just like teeing off on
each other which I think makes it work
it's super amusing but if you got locked
in an elevator with those four you'd
like kill yourself after after enough
time
look this is Jason laughing see look
he's just he's completely derailed your
podcast well you know what he's doing
he's counting this as top of funnel
marketing so getting back to marketing
um right getting back to marketing um so
I I actually cited this example in the
pitch deck I in Nevada I go mountain
biking my little e-bike you know I got
convinced to buy one of these bags
because they're super cool by the way
I'm part of the e-bike Revolution I
think e-bikes amazing biking do you
pedal at all yeah you do but it's like a
boost so if you're like
not in the most amazing shape like I'm
not and you're going up and down Hills
it makes it like super fun got it and um
where I am is super hit like I basically
you couldn't mountain bike this unless
you're in exceptional shape got it and
so this makes it such that someone who's
not in exceptional shape can actually do
it and it's kind of fun and cool and
it's like it's a cool Gizmo and it
anyhow um so I just posted a photo of it
and like oh cool like from where I ride
or whatever and then J Cal pipes and oh
that's cool what is that man tell me and
someone like tells him the model name
with like a review [ __ ] he goes and
buys it if you go to Jason's like page
now he mountain bikes he's my exact same
bike specialized turbo levo whatever
which is a great bike and if you ask
okay do the attribution problem who
takes credit like these things cost like
by the way like I bought the entry level
which is like six or seven K they go up
to like 20 25 okay these damn things so
who knows what model he bought so who
gets credit for like the several
thousand dollar bike is it me using
presumably my influencer audience is it
Twitter no no almost certainly it's
Google because I'm sure Jason you know
didn't go to specialize.com he just like
specialized turbo Evo and then you know
Google acts navigationally but it takes
if there was an attribution system there
run by Google of course they would take
full credit for that attribution even
though causally they didn't actually add
that much to the thing and so that's the
magic of attribution you determine what
is the ground truth
um ideally that ground truth and this is
the the Brave New World of web3 would be
a little bit more tied to like real
causality in the world because where
we've arrived on web 2 with a lot of
this funnel stuff it's very
sophisticated a lot of it a lot of it is
also very mythological right a seven day
attribution window for app installs Why
seven days you're telling me if I go
seven days in an hour later it's not
causally related but six hour you know
six days and 23 it is you know it's kind
of like a made-up thing that's not
really how it should work right and so
um at this point it's like congealed
into a system the way that web2 works
and it's this machine right you you
target people with a message to some
level of accuracy they come in you learn
new things because they buy things you
retarget them there's this whole
flywheel right and if you can figure out
how to get your ltvs above your CAC say
your lifetime value above your customer
acquisition costs to use the terms of
art then you've got a positive fraction
and your gold and you've got some Roi
Target and you're and if you can't and
you run out of money you lose and that
that is basically that is literally how
that is literally how everything half or
more of the technology industry works is
like give me money I light it on fire
but if I get more back and then it's
like a thing that I spend a dollar to
get to I'll do that all day long it'll
just light more and more money on fire
but if on the outside chance that I like
the money on fire and none comes back
then I'm [ __ ] right right right and
like that's literally the game right
well you have to create a marketing in
an ad Tech is a machine where I put in a
dollar and I get out of buck 30. and if
that's true then I'll be doing this all
day and if it isn't it's just like oh
nothing came out it's just gone and
that's it I'm out of money now right
like that is how all of webtoon to be
clear one of the reasons why so many
investors have gone and bought Amazon uh
Google Facebook stock Etc is because uh
who are you putting the money into the
machine is usually Facebook Amazon
Google right and they're sitting there
saying like maybe you get a dollar
Thirty or maybe you get zero but like
we're just the machine and like it's
somewhat on you to be able to figure out
how to use our machine correctly to get
the right and there's this whole stack
of technology that sits on top of these
players that make sure tries to make
sure that you get a buck 30 out of the
machine instead of 80 cents right
um and so
what's the problem here right that
doesn't exist in crypto web 3 right and
like if you want a billion real people
actually using web3 the reality is a
you're gonna have to like drink the web
2 user milkshake right and basically
take users from web to like webtoon web3
there's never gonna be like a flip over
moment obviously they're going to
coexist for years from now and in fact a
lot of I suspect in the future a lot of
people will be using crypto not even
realizing it yes I was like oh I have
some cool new experience you know I
don't know how it magically works that
like the same [ __ ] I bought on this game
works on that game but somehow I
actually own it and it just works right
I was asking so uh explain to me
Google's Tech stack like what I'm like
yeah what protocol does it run on and
they have no clue it's like that's where
we have to get to right uh and I
actually even think with Bitcoin to some
degree like there's a number of ones uh
strike and these other companies have
popped up and it's like uh can I send
you dollars across the Bitcoin Network
like you don't know if you're using vs
or Mastercard well Visa Mastercard
Bitcoin like who cares and so uh getting
there is going to be pretty important
for a lot of these Technologies yeah I
mean look at I understand you know
tribalism and geekery is what it is but
like all this chain love and the
tribalism of like Solana versus ethereum
it's like dude it's like caring about
um you know whether your favorite tech
company uses like Amazon or Google
Virtual servers like who gives a [ __ ]
you don't care and you shouldn't care
right only the sales people those who
got these characters they're gonna get
attribution of the sale and they can get
paid right right right and so yeah the
idea here is how do we create that
system for a blockchain but World which
is very different like web3 in my
opinion again I just got to this party
so to speak but is like the inverse of
web 2 in all sorts of interesting ways
um well I mean getting to this funnel
business right
um
in web 2 when you when you build these
systems and I've built these systems by
side cell side at every level of
sophistication and scale from Tiny YC
startup to Facebook right a lot of the
complexity the ad ranking the serving
the optimization the track all that [ __ ]
is happening top of funnel like at the
Facebook level and the downstream
attribution like the event like oh you
bought a thing you bought a 100 thing
okay great but that's like I mean it's
important but it's not that interesting
to model like it's literally an event
fired from like your Facebook app to SDK
to Facebook saying they bought thing one
two three four and they cost five
dollars like that's it right web web
three and again like as far as I know
we're like one of the few companies
doing it so and we're just figuring it
out a lot more the complexity is down
funnel right like modeling unit swaps
are poo it's kind of hard right's like
oh there's this point three percent swap
rate but then 0.05 is in this governance
token that they give back which by the
way whose value is fluctuating like more
wildly than the [ __ ] NASDAQ
um you know and uh what is the RP what
was the acquisition cost what is their
total monetization right these aren't
easy questions to answer right and while
the Upstream side of things to the
extent there even is any it's like well
these wallet got the uni Drop Like
that's it so one of the things uh
speaking of like recreating the world
right that we were talking about earlier
uh is yield farming was massive and I
just tapered off a little bit but still
exists and uh for those that don't know
are kind of the elementary explanation
was basically like somebody like hey
cool I'm gonna create a coin and uh that
coin is associated with a protocol and
that protocol uh has some amazing dream
of doing ABCD whatever uh but I have a
problem I wrote the code I have the uh
protocol usually there's a fork or
something or taking some open source
code and just copying it uh but nobody
knows I exist how do I get people to
come use it right and so what a bunch of
the people did is like well let's create
coins okay we got a bunch of coins what
do we do the coins well let's take a
portion of those coins and we'll give
them the people if they come and they
use it yeah and it's like okay so the
users are sitting there saying like wait
there's free money and so they show up
and they're like cool what do you want
me to do and there's always some crazy
thing like well buy some of our coins
and then like stake them say you won't
spend them and then you like earn a
thousand percent apy but there's only so
many coins available for people to do
this and so the more people who join the
lower the uh return gets and so
naturally what occurred is well guess
who was coming first it's like the
mercenaries not the missionaries they
don't give [ __ ] about your product they
just want the return it gets
commoditized down to some level and then
they just move on to the next right now
a huge piece of that is these projects
we're essentially doing this which is
like that is a customer acquisition cost
that they don't know of course yeah they
have no clue where those people came
from uh and they have no clue how to
remarket to them like all the problems
you're talking about and there was I'm
gonna put in big big air quotes billions
of dollars here because they sometimes
usually almost always were like invented
dollars coins whatever uh but still it's
a big business whether people think it's
sustainable or not and there was no data
around it yeah you know it's right when
I first started looking at youth farming
it's like I I couldn't get my head
around it's like wait no no I I
understand it there's just very little
to understand right like if you've got a
diagram in which you're not either
creating value or there's an exogenous
Arrow called money coming in this way
then you're kind of in some sort of
weird Ponzi like environment and but I
mean it's what it's wild right and and
again like put aside for a second uh uh
is it a posse is not what whatever but
just like if you were an investor like
let's say you're a crypto VC that's like
investing in these things uh
what do they put in the investor update
right like like there's no there's no
measurement there's no like it has to
just be about uh well no it but it's
like super Elementary stuff like here's
how many people are staking
right and and it's like so surface level
it's an engagement it's like it's like
now you sort of I mean yeah it's weird
right like you're basically firing money
out of a cannon and hopefully like
hoping somebody picks up the 10 Bill and
like walks in the store right and of
course almost everyone just walk doesn't
walk in the store but it's basically
kind of free money so you don't care
right it's like you know when money is
free acquisition costs are zero
definitionally and you just don't care
but then what happens when money stops
being free right and you have the crypto
crash and suddenly so how do you guys
think about like the attribution I guess
like what is the overlap with uh kind of
Legacy world like what are the things
from that world that you think you can
Port over versus like what are like new
things you need to figure out yeah I
mean you're right to frame it in two
different ways right so again there's
there's the web 2 versus web3
attribution problem and then there's
like this sort of endogenous weapon the
native stuff the native Freight so if
you talk a lot of Webster companies
we've talked to lots of web3 companies a
lot of them are actually doing
conventional web 2 user acquisition
advice like they buy ads on Facebook and
YouTube and you know they're fairly
untargeted they're using a lot of the ad
exchanges targeting they come to the
wallet sign-in page they sign in and
then that's it like the trail goes cold
they don't actually join anything from
and for those who don't know on the web
2 side there's a whole and again it's
all privacy gdpr complaint Etc but
there's a whole tracking mechanism there
through the click link and cookies and
device fingerprinting that basically if
you click on a Facebook ad and arrive on
a landing page they know it's you and
that you came from Facebook ad one two
three four but it doesn't stop there I
think it's a great piece to it is like
let's say that I was running ads to a
Shopify store right uh then they know
that cool you hit the homepage you
clicked on two products you didn't buy
those you went to a third product page
and then you converted and then they
realized like okay everyone who clicks
on those two product pages correct then
converts we probably should go show
those two product pages at the front of
the website to get a higher conversion
rate and the way that works is those
events that were down from the landing
page
whether they were an in-app or on a web
experience they were firing SDK events
and sdks just like a tracking package
basically back to Facebook saying this
user in an anonymous way did this thing
and so Facebook can actually join all
those things together when I was at
Facebook I mean probably when you're at
Facebook a little bit later so it was
but when I was at Facebook most of the
time there was no attribution system you
looked away from Facebook and Facebook
had no idea what the hell was going on
in fact some of the products they built
was the first time that you could
actually see outside of Facebook and
that's when Facebook ads started getting
good because you could actually detect
that the problem is that web3 right now
is stuck in like Facebook Circa 2012
land in which there's like this
basically Great Wall between the web 2
data trail and the web3 data trail and
it's really odd because because
Downstream on the blockchain there's all
sorts of data being written right a lot
of this gets into the whole privacy
angle which is one other conversation we
can have which is that web3 is weird in
that everything that actually happens is
in a public Ledger hard to query because
I mean the blockchain is fascinating for
many things it's a terrible user data
store it's horrible
um so you have to do a lot of
re-pivoting and querying of data to
actually get at it but everything is
stored but of course everything is
anonymous and everything Upstream of the
blockchain is completely unknown so you
know one of the first things we're going
to work on is actually joining yeah
um and it's it's not that hard to do
it's not trivial but you're gonna have
to have if web3 is going to succeed and
again have a billion real people on it
it's gonna have to get into the sort of
iterative flywheel of targeting people
on web 2 they come in they convert on
chain things happen you learn new things
you retarget them on web2 they come back
in like you need that cycle without that
cycle web3 is not going to succeed so
the whole idea here uh in the most
primitive uh sense is get people into
this new world yes understand who they
are either retarget them or people who
look like them Facebook look like
audiences imagine lookalikes in the
blockchain right yeah I I mean people
until you understand how the ad systems
work I don't think people quite realize
like uh the Facebook looks like audience
is a great example you can take a email
list and you can feed it into Facebook
and you can say to Facebook do you know
who the people who use these email
addresses are on Facebook and there's a
whole bunch of reasons how they may know
or what they Facebook profiles or
whatever and they say cool we have put
100 000 emails in we've now identified
30 000 of of the users those 30 000
people can you go through and strip all
the similarities so uh mail location
income job High School all this stuff
cool now can you find a bunch of other
people that look like those people on
the internet based on those priorities
and you come up with you started with an
email list now you come up with a whole
different set of people that you can go
Target that likely are similar to those
facts you go do that there's none of
that going on here yeah but in some ways
there's more data right and just a
stress your point even more lookalikes
are probably one of the most
underreported underrated but most
successful Facebook ads products ever
yeah I didn't work on it when I was
there but I remember the guy who first
pitched it and at first I'm like oh it
sounds kind of cool it could work it
works amazingly well because one of the
biggest pain points and web3 isn't there
yet but it will get there is that if you
talk to webto ever if you go to the qbr
business meeting as the PM and you go
talk to the big retailer who gets the PM
FaceTime they're like like we're smart
we have an in-house marketing team we
know how to reach all of our audience at
whatever the the actual match rate is at
every Outlet including you Google
everybody else I've got this million the
set of million gold in whales find me
another million just like them that's
the one thing you can uniquely solve and
if you ask the questions like oh how is
Facebook monetizing my data they're not
[ __ ] listening to to your phone they
don't give a [ __ ] about what you wrote
to your girl don't give anybody any of
that [ __ ] [ __ ] right that's it's just
ridiculous I'm gonna talk about it if
you got cash though they're interested
what are you buying what they care about
is like you're the guy who just you're
like the guy who just dropped 400 on an
REI tent and you guys try it all the
time you know each other that's
important right yes then you can be
foreign part of look or it turns out
your politics are very like similar to
somebody else's or whatever the case
might be that's where your Facebook data
actually gets used in terms of
similarity metric between between users
and so yeah at some point in the
blockchain hopefully soon so you think
that that will definitely be a thing
that happens look like audience with a
similarity metric among wallets in in BL
I'm shocked if there isn't somebody
working out we're probably gonna end up
working out at some point yeah and so
let's just go through a very Elementary
example here right so uh let's say that
person a has a wallet they've got uh
certain types of nfts in there they've
done certain on-chain activities and
maybe they have uh a bunch of uh Bitcoin
and other assets whatever you can
basically go look at that and then
almost score it to some degree and then
compare it to other wallets and then
find okay what other wallet has the same
T same kind of balance between certain
types of assets and as certain activity
uh Trail and okay these two wallets uh
are different people we believe but they
actually are very similar and so if this
person did something with you maybe this
person's interested that's right how do
you then go and and find who that person
is or communicate or Market to them well
I mean if you're using the web 3 tools a
few that exists it's like oh let's hit
them with an nft or token rep which
again like I know a lot of people can
just air drop them yeah drop like which
it's funny I talk about ads and what
three people get shocked it's like dude
you've already got ads in web like nft
is an ad like if you define an ad as a
piece of paid media that prompts a user
action which include lots of things we
already have ads in web3 and so like in
web 3 that's the only targeting
mechanism you have due to this weirdness
that you can send things to random mods
but again if you were to join web 2 with
web3 you could hit them on web 2 as well
right I mean I'm curious how creepy
people would find us here's uh we're
gonna float the idea you buy a thing on
chain and you get retargeted for that
inside your Instagram feed right imagine
that which happens commonly in web 2 as
it is right Instagram ads have Sky High
click through rates because the ads are
actually really well targeted imagine
doing that with blockchain data right
that that would change the game and
which and again it would be good for new
user acquisition what's called
prospecting like new users coming into
user thing and also re-engagement one of
the biggest problems you have is like
someone comes in uses the app they get
bored they turn out right like the end
of the funnel is usually a term and it's
like they turned out and they're gone
you've got to re-engage them you know
they like your product to a certain
degree maybe you have to hit them with a
different offer maybe they just forgot
and they have a new device and they
didn't download your app you have to
re-hit them right like again this is
just like the bread and butter of how
web2 growth works and web3 has very very
little of it right now what do you think
are the the downsides to the risks here
like is it just is everyone's privacy
they're just going to get [ __ ]
spammed with a million air drops and
like yeah but then they'll be yeah but
there'll be a tool that basically scrubs
all that [ __ ] from your wallet
automatically and you'll be fine with it
right like that that's just the arms
race of how these things go I mean I
think privacy is interesting so it's
privacy is one thing we thought about
I've actually I did a subset post about
it
um that's another place where like web 2
and web 3 are totally inverted right in
web 2 it's mostly the real unless you're
like in a non-account it's the real you
online but then what you do financially
and commercially everything else is kind
of private and it's actually heavily
regulated web 3 it's the opposite right
everything you do is public which is odd
but the real you is at least
pseudonymous right
um you know if Amazon went and published
on a public Ledger everything you bought
there you would have a [ __ ] meltdown
right and yet somehow by default that's
how web3 works and everybody is cool
with it weirdos it's like what and I've
always thought that as Amazon have like
a weirdo score right like like just sure
if you buy groceries if you buy you know
books whatever like you're you're in one
category and then they're just like oh
these people listen look what they're
[ __ ] buying today's episode is
brought to you by Alto I all right have
you wanted to buy Bitcoin or over 200
other cryptocurrencies in your
retirement account well now you can with
Alto Ira they allow you to buy Bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies in a tax advantage
way there's no account or setup fees and
it's super simple to get started you can
go today to Alto ira.com to get started
Alto ira.com
invest in Bitcoin or cryptocurrencies in
your retirement account and get all the
tax advantage while still holding
digital currencies altoira.com I mean
I'm sure I'm sure they had one but they
renamed it in the same way that Facebook
used to have the stalker coefficient
which was a simulator and now that you
guys select no no it's just coefficient
it's not soccer coefficient how many
times someone looked at your page
um
um so yeah I mean it's it's weird how do
you merge those worlds right and if you
look at to get wonky for a second if you
look at things like gdpr and CBA and
privacy regulation there's I mean it's
very difficult to comply with that and
have and the blockchain just basically
flies in the face of gdpr so how do you
actually reconcile those two worlds as
you will and is that a risk is that a
risk for some of these uh oh yeah Works
where uh gdpr is weaponized to basically
call the bluff on like are you
decentralized oh yeah yeah absolutely
and and dude I people like doubt it but
I will be saying I Told You So in five
years like crypto and privacy are like
these two trains that are headed on the
same track towards each other and the
only question is how far apart they are
before they Collide
um I've thought about this a lot from
the Bitcoin perspective of like it again
let's hold the Assumption which I think
99.9 of people agree uh Bitcoin is
decentralized all of these things that
uh are like oh you can't do that or this
is the rules or this or whatever like at
the end of the day it's just a
decentralized thing that there is nobody
who runs it and like the uh fact that
the founder is unknown walked away and
there's you have a decentralized network
like kind of checks the boxes
a lot of question marks on everything
else and I think that gdpr like I hadn't
thought about that being one of the
things that kind of snips out like what
is actually decentralized and what isn't
yeah because at a high level gdpr
surprisingly readable you can just go
read the thing although it's very vague
there's two key points that gdpr one is
who owns the data right and like
basically who takes the liability bullet
who gets dragged to Brussels when you
[ __ ] up basically and there's two
positions there's a controller and a
processor and there's different
terminology in CCPA but it's same thing
it's basically first party and third
party so if if you know if again I don't
know why I keep on citing REI but if
you're REI and you buy there they have a
first party relationship with you if I'm
their attribution system or Google
analytics I'm a I'm a processor not a
controller and so the rules are slightly
different you can't get away with murder
just because you're the processor but
it's a little bit different you want to
be a processor rather than a controller
by and large and then there's also the
sort of deletion immutability side of it
there's a bunch there but basically at
the end of the day if you want your data
gone modulus some restrictions and there
are some restrictions you can have a go
away right so does that mean that every
single blockchain is violating gdpr oh a
lot of them probably are yeah with that
well it's just every single one of them
uh you can't delete your data if well if
personal data is on the chain to begin
with like the so Step One is don't put
personality on the top on the Chain
right and so what does it mean to delete
could it be the case that you encrypt it
and burn the private key is that
deleting could be
um for my reading on it in the in some
jurisdictions that would count as
deleting and some it wouldn't the
problem with gdpr is that it's a it's
worded very vaguely and so it's
basically left sure that wasn't enough
I'm sure that wasn't intentional and
then it has to be decided by legal
precedent and there's very little
there's no precedent almost no president
because of blockchain but yeah if you've
got personal data on the blockchain
you're basically in violation then not
only that there's restrictions around
moving data you know overseas obviously
and if it is decentralized you've got
these nodes all over the place
um and this is not even going into
content moderation things like
see Sammy Kitty porn you know violent
material I the news came out that uh
Isis put an nft on I forget what chain I
think was a theorem
um and there's no way to get rid of it
now or no no it was ipfs I think wait
what did they do I didn't see this is
Wall Street I have no direct experience
it was just a Wall Street Journal thing
that I read but apparently Isis put some
sort of recruitment nft whatever that
means on I think it was ipfs yeah
I'm scared to uh even think about this
but like literally got like a [ __ ]
image of like dude no it gets worse so I
was talking I was in a debate with uh
Alex Stamos who's the head of the
Stanford internet Observatory former
head of security at our former employer
um and I kind of floated the thoughts
like yeah what if someone puts uh like
child sexual abuse material which is
obviously horrible on chain what would
you do and he's like oh no it's already
happened then I forget I I don't know I
didn't check his references but he's a
pretty informed guy so I'm sure he
wasn't talking out of his ass someone
apparently has put like horrible stuff
on chain so there was a story uh I think
it was the uh on ethereum uh I hope I
get these details right uh there was a
woman who was involved in some sort of
sexual assault or sexual harassment case
in China or it was the woman's friend I
can't remember which one but somebody
that had uh understanding the details uh
and it was basically getting kind of
quieted wouldn't want a coverage of it
whatever they took the details they put
it on the blockchain as like an
immutable Ledger and so like you know
censor me now uh type uh kind of calling
the bluff
um when I saw that I was shocked that we
hadn't seen that over and over and over
again since and I'm sure there's been
some cases but people don't talk about
it or whatever uh but yeah you can
extend this to like way more extreme
things than just like hey I have words
that nobody uh wants to get out
um and if you're running a node that
material is on your machine right think
about that and so like yeah like what
happens then
you're not a lawyer neither am I a
lawyer I don't know neither one of us
slept at uh uh Hampton Inn but like all
right I I assume if you are a politician
or in law enforcement and you want to
make a dent you probably go towards the
notes right
I guess so but how do you track them
down and uh yeah there's a bunch of
complexity of course right so like
decentralization again becomes really
[ __ ] important here
um and I guess it also begs the question
of like gdpr uh I think a lot of people
are like oh this is annoying I have to
collect you know hit uh accept all
cookies every single time I go to a
website and in Europe or whatever but at
the same time like gdpr is probably like
the watered down version of like some of
this other stuff and so could they then
start to shut down all these blockchains
uh or a lot of them because you only
need one violation for the entire thing
to be kind of out of Step
yeah I mean I'm a little bit in the
policy world through the Lincoln Network
which is this DC thing uh what is the
Lincoln Network a solinko network which
by the way is not the Lincoln project
just to get that out of the way it's a
completely different organization just
to be clear unrelated unrelated
organizations let's just get that I'm
assuming there's been some accusations
given the uh the need to clarify
um when when someone mistakes the two I
I see the director's Soul kind of
shrivel and die every single time
um so it's uh it's basically a think
tank
um non-partisan
um although obviously pro-business
protect that tries to bring together
like actual Tech practitioners with
policy in DC which is like this yawning
Lacuna that exists that should be
reconciled and so um yeah I help them
out because you know I I think look DC's
gonna exist regulation is going to come
in some form or another at this point
you know gdpr is real and so better to
inform it rather than have it off in la
la land
um and so you know it's weird that like
they're still fighting the Facebook
fight to like the [ __ ] we worked on 10
years ago right becomes like the media
thing five years after and then becomes
a DC thing like 10 years so they're
still fighting over the [ __ ] that we
built put it that way and so they're not
gonna fight about the thing we're
building now for another 10 years or
maybe five years so we've got some time
okay but at some point yes they will
they will catch up and but what's what's
fascinated by the conversation though is
uh it seems like the crazy thing like no
they'll never weaponize gdpr to go after
like centralized blockchains but like
[ __ ] yes they are like that like that's
a layup yeah if you don't like a certain
industry or a certain piece of
technology all you have to do is
literally find one instance that's right
and what also is unique here is that uh
in order to figure out did Facebook do
something wrong right whatever wrong
ends up being like you essentially have
to either have a whistleblower you have
to have somebody who like shows up and
is like I was a Facebook user this this
and this whatever like here's the
information or you have to somehow
subpoena the information from Facebook
like it's not like oh let me just go on
my computer do a block Explorer and
start you know screwing around and then
finding something and then yep you know
there you go and obviously this is why
law enforcement likes people transacting
on
uh but yeah it feels like this is like
such a no-brainer that of course they're
gonna weaponize this stuff yeah I mean
again I don't know how much overstresses
gdpr is real when you develop product
these days you know back in the day at
Facebook they thought about it there's
privacy Council but it was kind of like
the last check mark before you shipped
right now like you didn't want to do
something egregious right that was
obviously in not in the interest of the
user right right now it seems like uh
people are designing products with
privacy exactly on day one you don't
want to build yourself into a corner
where like oh [ __ ] now we can't comply
we can't ship it's like building a thing
that won't run and so it's a like I I
cannot stress enough to web three people
privacy is real it will come to your
house at some point soon you have to
take it seriously you're not going to
just talk around it it's like it's like
you know you've seen I'm sure you've
seen like the xkcd cartoon around like
the wrench thing where it's like how
crypto people think it works oh it's
like encrypted with I was like no no
here's this little five dollar Ranch
just hit the guys really gives them your
password guess what you're dealing with
people with the wrenches and the guns
and the jails and all the rest of it the
crypto can only Shield you to a certain
extent
um and so yeah I mean that yeah that
that that's going to happen at some
point what else do you think is a threat
or in the Privacy areas like gdpr it was
like just the blockchain being open and
can't delete data all that is one piece
of it are there other privacy things
that you guys are thinking about
no I mean I there's a whole D5 kyc side
of things right like which I'm somehow
less familiar with in the Privacy side
um
no I don't see any deep existential
risks I mean I I do think there's gonna
I mean there obviously is some like
organ rejection around like the culture
of crypto and like unfettered freedom
and movement that just doesn't jive with
our current globalized world but
everyone knows that um I do find it
absolutely hilarious that everyone's is
uh attacking the thing and I spend all
my time thinking about Bitcoin
um but like
it is probably the most American ethos
like base technology that we have of
just like you can do whatever you want
to do and uh uh you don't even have to
tell people who you are right like that
to me just screams American ethos of
like Freedom yeah and yet America seems
to be one of the most uh cautiously
abrasive like they're not China well
then I would say they're not not China
but but they definitely uh the default
is like we don't like this thing yeah
and now there's some education happening
and there's some politicians who maybe
you know are kind of on the pro side but
like
it would feel like if they understood it
to you know the absolute my new details
they would be like man we should do
everything we can to make this
successful now there's downside and
potentially risk some of the the
benefits that they already enjoy but
like it does feel very weird yeah I mean
there's that Viral threat from uh was it
uh Punk um forget the number actually
659 maybe six one five nine yeah maybe
um who said you know if I got it wrong I
I was talking about somebody I'm sure
we got canceled we're done because you
forgot the number
um but you like trying to remember IP
addresses rather human readable domains
like uh one two one point six nines I
still remember some of those action back
in the day really yeah well because you
know you had like EarthLink and you had
your stable IP you'd have to enter in
the DNS table it's like uh uh you ever
try to think about how many phone
numbers that are in your phone book do
you actually know by heart oh God nine
at this point zero like zero there are
people who like I absolutely should know
them and I don't and it's kind of scary
right if you're in jail I'm like call
your wife it's like uh have my phone
okay exactly I promise I won't go on the
internet I will not tweet I just need
the phone yeah but getting back to his
tweet thing it's like his point was like
you know crypto is so American in so
many ways like if there is a crypto
Century America should dominate it right
because it's like the most American
thing ever I mean I agree it's true
right like I mean yeah China just will
never accept a truly crypto reality it's
odd that uh this is a free country man
like that we should be able to say that
more right around crypto but uh that's
weird this need for control I don't get
it you know and how much of this is uh a
misunderstanding or like lack of
Education versus like no they actually
do understand and I'll I'll give you a
uh two examples so like Brad Sherman uh
one of the politicians in California uh
he was one of the first ones back we
should ban uh Bitcoin and crypto like
like get rid of this stuff it's a threat
to the American dollar and like I mean
he was just went like full extreme on
the on the other end and then you have
people uh like you've got uh Warren
Davidson uh you've got Senator lamis uh
up in Wyoming uh you've even seen uh
Mayors uh you got Suarez you got
Governors like all these other people
who are like no actually like you either
want to embrace it or like I'm agnostic
like I don't want to ban it but like uh
I also don't don't want to run head
first
it feels like the bride Shermans of the
world are like uh very well educated
it's not that he doesn't understand it
it's almost that he understands it so
well that he's trying to play chess like
three four five steps ahead and he
sounds insane right and people are just
like that's stupid you're just like an
old man yelling and screaming uh
but it seems like everyone just gets
labeled with like oh you don't
understand Congress doesn't understand
politicians understand but like the more
I listen to them talk like more of them
seem to understand than maybe they let
on
maybe so
um
yeah it's unfortunate I haven't actually
followed that politician's uh trajectory
he uh his biggest donors are uh credit
card companies oh so a lot of people are
yeah I like the idea of actually
politicians should dress up like NASCAR
drivers with like other donors as like
little logos so every time he goes in
front of a camera he's a little Visa
logo like he's a [ __ ] point of sale
system that that would be uh idea do you
think you think they would change uh
their actions oh of course they would
because it would look so ridiculous
sitting there like [ __ ] on crypto
with like a Visa logo like a little
square checkup I've always thought that
they should have to take like a super
elementary test before they go to these
hearings and like remember the guy who
is like uh uh you need to shut down
finsta like the fake Instagram and they
were like uh sir like that's not a thing
whatever like they should have to take
like a five question multiple choice
question uh test if you don't get four
out of five right like you're not
allowed to question the people yeah
because you just literally don't have
the basic understanding of like what is
Instagram yeah I mean one of the things
I learned so I have gone to DC again in
the context of the Lincoln Network and
talk to some of these staff I wouldn't
name the staff it doesn't matter but you
know people whose Senators who make loud
pronouncements without the internet and
you know they're not as dumb as you
might think right to be honest like a
lot of these staff so by the way DC so
like the figurehead is whoever but their
staff are like 23 right and just got out
of American University and it's like
their first job and they're a staffer
and they've been told to go figure out
crypto
and then like Lincoln network shows up
with like oh here's Antonio who came
from the industry talked to him and like
yeah explain to us web dream like oh
okay where do I start and so like
they're not necessarily dumb and they're
not necessarily anti but yeah I don't
know somehow between that 23 year old
getting the memo and reading on the
internet whatever and what comes out of
the mouth of whoever Josh Hawley or
whatever
um there's a lot of steps in there
um and obviously that politician knows
that you know he needs to sing for his
supper so to speak to keep his job
um I I think one of the other things has
happened in American life I love zooming
out to 30 000 feet it's like at some
point in the 60s we decided that we're
no longer a frontier Society right what
do you mean like so there's this uh
there's this famous essay by I forget
his name written uh in the early 20th
century about the frontier in American
life right the notion of there being
some untrameled friend tear where a man
and a woman a family can go out and
create their new reality and staking you
home and like we had the Homestead Act
in Alaska until the 60s and 70s where
the government would literally give you
land and say as long as you live here
for five years it's yours right like the
United States had that right I mean
think about that because when I was
buying land up in the Northwest I was
thinking of buying Alaska they don't
have the homestead act anymore but the
state does basically raffle out like
land basically way cheaper than in the
1870s um read a book right now and uh
basically as people pushed West like you
just got to get it put into the land
deed right that like that's yours that's
yours uh yeah that's how you got it
right I mean the football team the
Oklahoma Sooners were the ones who got
there soon sooner who like jumped the
federal like date to actually claim land
or whatever because there were stake
jumpers as they're called anyhow um at
some point in the 60s after the Apollo
program we decided that's it we're no
longer a frontier society that pushes
into the unknown and everything's about
control and Safety and Security and I
think those things have just gotten
worse in time and uh I think web3 is an
interesting New Frontier one of the
things that draws me to it makes me
think of uh I had a bit of a bust up
with uh
our our friend Keith were boy and Max
leptin a week ago over the differences
between web 2 and web3 and uh what what
did you say what did I say what did I
say I'm such an [ __ ] what did I say I
didn't try being an [ __ ] but I did
say it was a sentiment I actually
honestly did feel right which is that
web again using web3 this kind of hazy
term just to refer to this thing
um feels kind of like what web2 felt
like 10 years ago right okay like when
you were walking around South Park and
Soma which now was just empty by the way
it's like oh there's the founders of
like this weird Airbnb thing and there's
Uber and then there's this part like
there was this thrilling bracing feeling
of like lots of weird [ __ ] is going on
right like we're replacing every service
and like it's part of what led to chaos
monkeys right where like these chaos
monkeys that run around and completely
rejigger everything and there's this
tremendous feeling of energy and
enthusiasm and forward-looking and and
there was a lot of to be honest I
wouldn't say religiosity a lot of
ideology around like things are worth
disrupting for the sake of disrupting
and even if it isn't obviously clear why
this is better now it's still worth
doing right and somehow web 2 for a
bunch of reasons I can speculate about
just no longer has that feeling and it's
like
well
a lot of it was like the anti-tech turn
I think of media in 2016 with the Trump
election that there was this Tech
backlash which I think is a lot is very
inventive you look at most polls most
Americans like the tech that they use
they don't actually hate Facebook
um and certainly if you look at
Facebook's usage chart they don't seem
to hate it
um
part of it was I don't know maybe
something gets tapped out right like
dude how many services can you put on
this phone like how many things can I
buy on this [ __ ] like how many people
can I make up here with [ __ ] on this
phone at some point it's like a new user
flow a new sign-in process a new sharing
button like it's all the same [ __ ] you
need to refactor things like to me like
literally I said this in the thread even
if web3 ends up being I suspect it will
converge to that like yeah it'll be an
interesting new set of infrastructure
and like a new way like it'll enable
some new interesting use cases but to be
honest it could end up being something
somewhat similar to web2 but as long as
we get rid of the fan companies it'll be
good right like because it's like any
company that starts now is literally
like a little a little a little you know
a little dwarf a little miniature person
kind of jumping in between the legs of
these elephants and as moment the moment
you get any level of traction you know
Apple's gonna show up and expect it's 30
on the App Store and by the way you have
to use its ad because they nuked
attribution through its ATT thing
[ __ ] it up for everybody else all in
the name of privacy all the name of
privacy yeah privacy one of the crazy is
business strategy moves that we've seen
in a long time and it appears to be
working and no one seems to be talking
about it outside of like a very small
group of people who pay attention yeah I
mean I'll say it again because I say it
everywhere it's like dude it's like
privacy is one of those things like
security like if you turn the knob that
says privacy on the other knob on the
other side of the novice has competition
right and like there are no Solutions in
this world there are only trade-offs
right there is no perfect privacy
solution you have to find a trade-off
and you can crank up the knob to 11 but
that means there's only gonna be two
games in town Google and apple and
that's it if we go for a Max privacy
world so think about it if you want a
Max privacy world or not because that's
not gonna I think it's not going to be a
good world but that that's also one of
the things right that we're in a Max
privacy world like
I had this conversation with uh the
Stanford people Renee and Alex last week
at a Lincoln Network event it's like you
realize this regime of like content
moderation combating misinformation
privacy all that does is like super
[ __ ] raise the bar such that only in
the Googles and Facebooks can actually
comply with it can you imagine starting
on Instagram now and possible and and
having to feel the content moderation
team with like the expected standard of
everyone feeling nice and cuddly and
safe all day it would be possible it
would be impossible there's no way to do
it right yeah the other uh I've always
thought of this
um or these are borrowed ideas uh
Bitcoin was started in a way where no
one was paying attention for five six
years until like crypto showed up or you
know whatever you want to think about it
uh now
you could never recreate that like
there's too many people there's
literally Venture capitalists running
around the world right trying to find
the next thing like whatever like it
just would be nearly impossible to do
um same thing with a lot of these
companies right is Instagram nobody
cared about content moderation for like
almost a decade right right and then all
of a sudden I was like hey why is this
person on here hey what about this what
about this and like you see it now like
uh we I mean this is uh crazy we had a
interview with Andrew Tate in person
live whole thing is up for a whole month
1.4 million views or so on it all of a
sudden we get an email take it down by
YouTube why
misinformation no other details no
anything uh I see him saying the same
thing on other channels on other videos
like all the stuff and all I could think
to myself was like
who gets to decide that right yeah and
like by the way there's things that you
and I probably were tweeting two years
ago that like people were like that
sounds crazy and now they're like duh
right like it's all changing I don't
know it's just a weird world that we're
moving towards yeah misinformation it's
funny you know there's a crack about
like you know people don't believe in
God anymore but there's certainly a lot
of devils
and misinformation is like this
catch-all it's like oh it's just it's
evil unless it's just a misinforming I
mean it sounds bad right like I don't
want to share misinformation I mean like
you don't either it's like you ever seen
the comedian uh I think it's Chris Rock
I think does it uh see the Christopher
Cat Williams can't remember uh he talked
about insurgents and War he's like the
greatest marketing thing ever was he
called him insurgents like they were
like uh hey we're gonna go kill the
Insurgent service like I'm not an
Insurgent I don't know any insertions I
kill them all right but they're like hey
we're gonna go kill humans be like whoa
whoa time alley who are they what they
do like why are we gonna do this same
thing with misinformation like you just
label it misinformation and everyone
just walks away and says yeah those
people are bad they spray best
information yeah exactly when you think
about the censorship how much of that is
going to come as well except by gdpr and
the Privacy like do you think that that
I mean ideally right like will come is
it wasn't it christics and you said um
can't be evil is better than don't be
evil right and that you know don't be
evil was obviously Google's mantra for a
long time and obviously I don't think
they're living up to it now and even
they themselves would probably concede
that they don't use that they don't even
use right yeah there's a good reason why
they don't use it anymore
um and so if you design systems that are
kind of uncensorable of course like
uncensorable in reality is often not
uncensorable in theory to be honest
um but um
yeah I don't know I mean it's
so another divide I've seen inside I
talk to lots of people with weird ideas
and you hang out with weirdos long
enough you hear a lot of weird stuff but
um it's interesting one of the divisions
that you see like I I do think there's
this notion in like statistics and
machine learning like latent variables
what that means is you've got a model
that's got like features a b and c and
then they're behaving in weird ways but
in fact there's this latent variable
that is actually the thing driving the
phenomenon that are highly correlated
and maybe actually lead to A and B but
you're looking at like the wrong thing
right or you're looking at the it's
almost like being in Plato's Cave you're
looking at the shadow of reality you're
not looking at the reality so I think
one of the sort of latent variables in
society is what is your orientation
towards institutions you're either an
institutionalist or you're like an
anti-institutionalist and it doesn't
necessarily mean against institutions in
general we're not in an anarchist book
collective in Portland or whatever it
just means like the current set of
Institutions do you think there's a
salvageable middle that like we have to
preserve because you talk to a lot of
people who again some of them have even
like queued up and spit out by
institutions
and you can tell like they still believe
in them they just wish they were running
them which is different than saying well
kind of burn it all down or actually I
have like a completely different
institutional model that I actually want
to realize this is my problem with like
the hardcore uh extreme Anarchist view
that uh just naturally shows up with uh
with some of crypto Bitcoin whatever is
like uh
no we want some sort of order again we
can have different order we can agree on
different rules we can do like all these
things and everything but like uh I
don't think we want to go back to again
go to like the 1800s where like
literally your defense system was
essentially like could you pull your gun
faster than whoever showed up to your
house in the middle right right like
that doesn't seem like a world we want
to live in uh and then also like uh
there's a number of different things
that uh especially local governments do
that uh make life easier again you can
argue should they exist should they not
whatever but like it does make life
easier but institutions are the kind of
the same thing like it goes back to like
the Dow thing like okay we're gonna have
this thing we're all gonna like work on
something but like there's no
organization there's no anything like
what do you end up getting like oh we
should get some downs we should get
divisions of companies whatever and then
you get also like Bill Gates he's the
pirate in the garage but lives long
enough and now like he is the man right
everyone is like this guy you know the
evil billionaire or whatever I think
that's a common thing by the way 50
years ago he wasn't right right I think
that's a common thing it's funny I so we
have job listings that are gonna go out
but hopefully will be live by the time
this episode
but one of the taglines is like you know
uh
come be a pirate now that web 2 is the
Navy right it's kind of a spin on the
Steve Jobs line right because and again
getting back to my debate with Keith and
Max lovekin and some of these what I
call web2 Boomers right where it's like
you used to and I'm like their same age
or even younger or older but it's like
dude like you used to be the crazy
pirate in the garage and now you're like
fat and happy and sitting at the top of
like the web 2 pile and you think you
still are that Rebel but it's like no
you're not right and it's like what I
wanted to ask him it's like think about
the younger version of you like
literally the 18 year old version of you
are they working at the companies that
you're running now are they working in a
completely different ecosystem where you
know the but but I do think that it's
um
it's split so like I I I agree with the
sentiment what I would say though is
there it's not just exclusively like
Bitcoin crypto world as like where all
of the chronicle Pirates are going I
think a lot of them are I talked to uh I
guess it doesn't sound as weird with
tech people but like the average person
like I talked about 18 to 23 year olds
but like yeah they're super excited
about this but you know what else
they're really excited about like the
whole like American dynamism are they
okay cool and they want to go work on uh
defense stuff or space or like whatever
and like there's probably two or three
other Industries if we sat down and like
I really thought about like hey where
are so many people going
but they're not going to work at
Facebook they're not going to work at
Google they're not going to work at
these places and in some way the people
who are going to work there who are
young are like uh the people who
historically would have gone to IBM or
wherever it's just like now these new
companies are like a little bit shinier
but it's the same thing right and so
I do wonder how many like fintech is
really interesting right like fintech
not crypto stuff
is that still seen as like Cutting Edge
or are young people saying I don't want
to go work at another
banking you know like Legacy banking
type uh thing I don't care if it has a
digital kind of skin around it or
are they saying no like [ __ ] it I'm
gonna go do the crazy defy thing that
like you know has a one percent chance
of working yeah obviously I'm not in
that age bracket but I would speculate
that they're probably not they're not
going I mean I I don't think
I don't think the world's most
aggressive ambitious Talent is going
into fan companies no it's that is not
my vibe yeah but I think most Venture
capitalists would agree with that yeah
why why did they push back well because
because web2 has become the man right
like I often think of um John Perry
Barlow uh one of the founders of eff
back in the day um back when it was eff
and not what it is today
um wrote uh eff has kind of gone the way
of ACLU it's like wait
he used to defend all these crazy people
in the name of free speech and now
you're actually part of the man and so
like anyhow but back in the day right
when eff was the thing he read this
famous cyberspace Manifesto that I think
was very impactful I mean even earlier
than me but it was written in the 90s
um and you know he railed against these
uh weary Giants of Flesh and steel right
of like the industrial world and that
cyberspace and Tech was going to be the
antithesis of that it's going to be the
reaction against that like they're the
Navy we're the Pirates and we're this
new world and the reality is that
companies like Facebook and Google have
become the weary Giants of not
necessarily flesh and steel but whatever
um and they've they've become part of
that Borg they're no longer the response
to the Borg they're part of it and you
know will that happen to crypto uh at
some point I mean if it lives long
enough that's probably the natural life
cycle of everything
um
but that's a long way we're a long way
to go from 30 40 years yeah probably a
long way yeah I do think a lot about
um in some ways this specific industry
has retaught so much about economics
technology but also just like how did
America become America right like you go
back and you read and you're like oh wow
a tax revolt like yeah I'm like oh [ __ ]
right like wow okay and then like oh uh
I don't know uh The Federalist Papers
like you go and you like read it and
you're like publish anonymously they're
all a non-conscious posters all the
founding fathers were non accounts
they'd all get content moderated now I
wasn't going to go down that rabbit hole
but like again it goes back to if you
really George III would have worked on
Facebook if you really start to look at
a lot of American History like there are
things that I think today's uh kind of
pro-america elite incumbent uh believes
that is in direct violation of kind of
the original ideals of uh what America
uh was supposed to be and I would argue
still in many places is yeah but that
bifurcation is wild because like go read
the documents go do the work it's just
like no eyes take this idea now and I
have a different idea of where we should
go yeah I know I mean there were Radical
ideas
um I read a piece for Wired in like 2017
that was like argued you know we're not
this change in model of Journalism from
like fact checked reportage coming from
the New York Times all the News That's
fit to print blah blah blah blah blah
it's like dude defining fathers didn't
live like that at all for starters they
all had newspapers they're all
newspapers they're all pamphleters I
think it was either John or Sam Adams
that he he was actually at the Boston
Tea Party like literally throwing the
teeth and then he reported about as if
he wasn't there he totally lied about it
and then he held the meeting for it in
his office and the printer's office
before it actually happened he was
completely engaged there was no
neutrality there's no anything right it
was like a total joke Benjamin Franklin
running or at least whatever it was 10
or 15 different pen names
um they all attacked him I did read that
recently actually didn't like that is
wild yeah Ben Franklin literally had
like it's kind of like having a message
board and having a bunch of pseudonyms
and then just talking to each other
exactly until almost
probably a lot of crypto companies are
doing as well and and uh also if you
kind of think about it like uh
there's nothing new like this is all
human nature [ __ ] like how do you solve
the cold start problem in you know 1850
like I don't know just [ __ ] just get
out my uh feather and just start writing
from different names and next you know
people will come show up yeah yeah but
you know I think we're maybe a bolder
people back then we were willing to put
up with just confronting I don't know
it's hard to say on the one hand I think
one of the bad things about social media
is that you're constantly forced to
defend like your basic moral foundations
like it's like you go to Twitter and
it's like getting kicked in the face
right and it's like I've kind of gotten
used to it a little bit and we probably
both have but it kind of sucks like your
average normal person would never do
this right and like at some point it's
like you know it's like running a
company right if you have debates about
foundational everything in a company
your company goes nowhere like there's
some things you have to say look these
things are Beyond debate we're just not
going to address these things anymore
that's it we talk about these things
which is where we think the alpha is
um and somehow
yeah we've lost it as Society it's weird
because on the one hand they put up with
an enormous amount of disagreement but
everyone thinks oh everyone just agreed
everything but it's like are you kidding
absolutely not I mean literally we had a
sitting vice president [ __ ] American
Revolution yeah yeah I mean well Aaron
Burr literally a sitting vice president
shot a former Secretary of the Treasury
and then just went back to work as if
nothing had happened right he like laid
low in Georgia for all and they just
went back and said well sorry oops I
killed Alexander Madison Hamilton sorry
and it's uh yeah
so but yeah do you feel like uh things
like sub stack and kind of like the
right of the individual uh whatever like
what is going to be the impact is it
just like no we have coexistence there's
like uh kind of like college Gamers like
a list disrupt college and it's like
dude Harvard's not going anywhere right
I don't care what you say Harvard Yale
MIT whatever and so like sure you might
disrupt like the uh third or second tier
you know colleges same thing here with
media is like you'll get the independent
voices and you'll get the concentration
of like two to four really big
organizations they survive and everyone
else is [ __ ] yeah I mean when you yeah
when I've had this debate about
institutionalist versus
anti-institutionalists with
institutionalists they're like okay Mr
Anarchist so what are you gonna replace
in your times with they're ready like I
still need to know what's going on in
the world that's a good point right like
again obviously I'm on sub stack they've
they've done very well by me like I'm
very Pro the company I know the founders
you know that said are they gonna fill
the whole of conventional media fully
not necessarily I don't know if they
want to right like you probably don't
want to yeah I've never specifically
asked them that but like I I get the
sense that they're just like no we just
want individual people to write and uh
there's a lot of value to that
I mean look the MSM does do some good
like occasions you read a piece in the
Atlantic or the New York Times like wow
that was actually pretty good like I
remember like the Afghanistan pullout
which was a total disaster and when they
like vaporized an entire family and
killed a bunch of people which no one
had any accountability for which is a
complete you know disgrace uh the New
York Times actually this amazing
reporting and like okay no here's the
shot here's the thing here's what
happened we interviewed the family's
like oh this felt like an actual like on
the ground report it was like Cloris
award uh the CNN uh journalist she's on
the ground and uh she's surrounded by
Taliban remember straight and she's like
reporting and and you could tell you're
like yo that's [ __ ] dangerous as [ __ ]
right and and I remember people just
like taking pictures being like this
woman is risking her life to tell this
story right now and like I don't care
what you think about that organization
or whatever you just gotta tip your hat
and say hey that woman's doing work that
is important and uh should be blasted
out by everyone possible uh because
there's not very many people willing to
go do that yeah yeah I know I agree I
mean of course the counter argument's
like well you know like in Ukraine they
use telegram a lot like when I was in
Ukraine I was just like listen to like
you see a lot of these videos come along
so you have the closer reward experience
you don't feel like it's disembodied
voice telling Yoko here in narrative
it's like this blurry video of some
weird [ __ ] that happened in some random
Town um
yeah but
hard to say hard to say right because
yeah I mean if we return to that
previous journalistic model of basically
advocacy journalism things are very
different right the notion of there
being some objective truth in a national
narrative kind of goes away and things
get very fragmented and again to the
extent that like your Regional newspaper
had like I'm sure Southern newspapers
were very different than Northern
newspapers and like Miami Herald in the
80s was very different in the New York
Times the LA times but there was still a
cohesion around it and like your area of
concern was relatively limited and now
that your area of concern is global it's
odd that we don't actually have a global
reality and we should discuss it I think
that's part of what you see when like
red and blue just to give them two broad
labels for debating online they're
talking about different realities right
and it's the clearest proof of that I
think this started in like the Beto
Cruise race I don't know if it started
but it at least I noticed it is when
like remember when I forget which it's
funny they've blurred in my mind I
forget which was which but like
literally one's like actual ad was the
attack ad for the other side like
literally it's like our moral
foundations are so different what you
consider to be like the Suman bonam like
political good is this person's abs loot
evil and like literally he just ran like
the Beto ad is like this is what Beto is
like that's my attack ad is his ad
that's how different we are
um that seems untenable I I do uh I do
believe that uh American politics is on
the precipice of absolute uh full plunge
into like what I call Meme Warfare so
like everything that we've seen so far
has been like the extremes of kind of
like a web 2 Fiat world or whatever you
want to call it uh I think that Trump
was the first to kind of break uh he was
selling the hats and he was you know
saying all the bombastic [ __ ] and uh the
debates he was uh more so an Entertainer
uh to some degree and and like you can
start to see it happening yeah uh but I
think within the next two to three
presidential elections we're just gonna
see a level of uh in the trenches
internet native like Warfare uh and like
information uh kind of battle
that will blow the 2015 versions of
ourselves out of the water like how is
this happening yeah and part of what I
think is fascinating about it is like so
like that is pretty simple but I think a
lot about like coinbase ran that uh
super uh kind of uh genius ad where they
just had the uh QR code bouncing around
like what is the political equivalent of
that and like somebody's gonna figure
out what it is and they're gonna start
doing that stuff and then you're gonna
see all the stuff on Twitter and
what you realize in some way is like now
everyone's an actor like everyone on the
internet has something when the
politicians like figure out the game
we're going to want to get off the
internet like like it's going to get to
the point where we're just like holy
[ __ ]
you know that I mean that's a deep so a
couple couple reactions to that one to
Steel Man it for a second right it might
be a good thing that like we're never
gonna have a civil war because the Civil
War is gonna be on Twitter and to be
honest we're all like too fat and happy
and lazy to actually like run a mile and
fire rifle anymore like Antietam is not
happening ever again right and so it's
gonna be like it's gonna be like Twitter
and TM which obviously has a lower body
count um so maybe arguably it's it's a
good thing
um that we're creating this virtual
reality although it means that I think
when reality does intrude in the form of
pandemic of the Ukraine war we just like
can't rock like we just don't understand
it and again this full-on meltdown
remember right and again I think it's
real like current thing theory is real
and that there is like the pseudo event
thing on the other hand if you think
everything is a current thing then
reality becomes but you know I don't
know if you know the Thinker Bruno
Matias he says Portuguese um I I
interviewed him on my podcast a couple
years ago yeah he wrote a book uh called
the history has begun and it's it's the
thought is that the US has decided to
wrap itself inside virtual mean Warfare
basically what you're saying and make
reality kind of optional but then of
course when reality becomes non-optional
the problems begin like with the
pandemic War so again I I suspect you're
right
um
um but yeah um the other thing I would
say I lost my train I thought was the
other thing
um
anyhow uh but yeah I agree with you that
um in some sense that's uh that's gonna
be the problem yeah the the piece uh
that I think is concerning about it is
like right now all the politicians are
like a gazillion years old and like they
use flip phones and don't have email or
like well you know whatever like oh we
like to like make fun of them uh what
happens when like the 30 year olds are
uh rampant and they're now like 40 or 50
and they understand the internet really
well
um because I actually think that a lot
of times what we're seeing so like I
have this theory that like Trump and AOC
are the same person right right like
they both understand the internet they
understand how to entertain they
understand how to get attention and
stuff uh and um I had uh Mike Solana uh
on and we were talking about uh the
arrest I'll put that in air quotes of
the Congress people did you see this oh
the business of yeah yeah and they like
they had their hands behind their back
but they weren't arrested remembered
okay I remember what I was thinking
sorry but yeah no so okay sorry
um so I get excited as you can tell okay
um that's why I'm excited
there's this really overlooked and
underrated book called media aided by an
anthropologist named Thomas uh kind of a
weird last name
is his last name and um came out in like
the early odds kind of ignored now
um and he just talks about exactly what
you just said everyone being an actor
the thought of being mediated is a weird
thought and we've all taken it as normal
but it's strange and it's only when you
pull yourself out of the Matrix again to
kind of red pill yourself that you sort
of that you sort of realize it
um the example he cites uh which is
interesting it's a couple examples one
is you notice that back in the day
nobody asked themselves the question
where were you when you heard about
Pearl Harbor right because the notion of
you almost in a phantom limb way
experiencing something at a distance and
your personal experience of being a
thing wasn't a thing yet people heard
about Pearl Harbor because they
literally it was like a rumor on a radio
two days later like it was not a thing
they directly witnessed however the JFK
shooting was the first time similar to
the 911 things like where were you when
that happened because there was this
feeling like you saw the towers go down
or you saw JFK get shot and you felt you
were sort of physically in meshing it
even though you weren't right so
something has happened there the other
example he cited which is interesting
um he was at one of these act I guess he
was interested in acting when he was
younger when he's acting studios in New
York one of these method acting things
in which I've probably never done acting
or stand up neither have I I'd be too
embarrassed what are you talking about
do you stand up right now well yeah I
know but unfortunately I have to do it
but um but he's like you know it's one
of these things where they give you an
assignment like oh you've just been shot
or you just heard that your uncle died
and then you're supposed to channel the
emotion and do it and like literally as
I understand it everybody in the acting
school starts acting as if their uncle
just died right which sounds very weird
and fake but I guess in acting that's
what you have to do and so anyhow it was
uh I guess
um what uh November 22nd 1962 or 61 or
whatever it was and someone opens the
door and says the president has been
shot and everyone starts acting with the
grief of it right for like 10 minutes
and the guy comes in is like no no the
president actually got like he got shot
right now like it's on TV and then
everyone just like freaked out because
they realized they were supposed to be
acting about the thing but then they had
the real flood of emotions of actually
being the thing and the guy said he was
so freaked out about it he like ran out
the room and never did acting again
because it was such huge you realize
that the media had made us all actors
we're all kind of on TV all the time
right whether it be for like a selfie or
a tick tock or this podcast or whatever
and it's a very different mode to be the
real you and act in a very
unsubconscious way versus the thought
that there's the external author looking
in that there is this fourth wall that
you're addressing all the time there's a
very different reference frames and
Humanity didn't used to think they were
on stage all the time oh yeah now we do
I I see the biggest places the
self-censorship like yes exactly
happens to all of us yeah we're all uh
victims of it uh I've been talking to a
couple of people uh mutual friends of
yours and eyes that uh it's like
becoming so prevalent where we've even
in this podcast probably multiple times
said like oh I didn't say this or I was
going to Tweet it but then I didn't know
uh you know can I add an endless steer
away from this or whatever and like it's
not necessarily like quote bad like in
the sense of oh if you would have said
it it's just like I don't want to deal
with the headache of that I don't want
to actually have to defend uh why I
believe something and so self-censorship
uh is like a huge [ __ ] problem that
is only going to get worse and worse
over time to the point where like does
90 of the society just say the same
things over and over again not because
they actually believe it but just
because they just don't want to deal
with it like yes yeah I mean this is all
about like hovels green grocer thing in
which for those who aren't familiar with
it um
is an essay about a green grocer who
basically hangs a sign with solidarity
for whatever the Communist cause was not
because he deeply cared about he just
didn't want to deal with the hassle
um speaking of Communists you know he
was really good at the self-centric ship
uh people who live in dictatorships so
uh one of the stories they did for Wired
actual reporter story was in Cuba so I
went to Cuba uh as you might know Miami
humans typically don't tend to go back
by and large unless they have family
there or something but I went back for
the sake of Wired Magazine in 2017 to
talk about Cuban internet which is a
whole other Story how they get internet
and mostly don't get internet
um but one thing I was just I was in
Havana which is kind of like a nice part
and there's you know there's kind of a
media very small media and texting there
and there's just starting to be like
bloggers and you know the equivalent of
you know Maddie Iglesias to draw a
random example of people who have like
an online presence and they sort of do
reporting right which again in Cuba's
big news because officially you can't do
journalism you have to be part of the
guild and it's super centered and I was
sitting in a cafe like a reasonably
fancy cafe and the guy was going on
about how he had done reporting from the
eastern part the country they had
recently in Hurricane the government's
response was obviously terrible because
the government's kind of uncomfortable
it's shocking but of course saying that
is like you can't say it in public and
so you know I was trying to get at the
guy I was interviewing for the piece
it's like so what do you know what do
you hope to get out of it by reporting
on this thing it's like well
um you know by by highlighting the
government's you know lack of of
response to it we hope to impact
um you know the human democracy in the
Cuban election that I'm like and of
course I did not self-censor because I
had not been raised inside it's like
what are you talking about Cuba isn't a
democracy this is this is tyranny and I
just blurted out in the cafe and
everyone just stops and stares at me and
it's as if I had like ripped a fart in
the elevator and everyone just like
pretends it didn't happen and the guy
just kept on talking as if I hadn't said
anything and it's just like uh I'm like
oh [ __ ] I'm sorry I forgot I forgot this
is not how this works here I have to
like shut the [ __ ] up and then you
realize as I got there and I hated the
place it was terrible I mean the humans
are great but the the situation is
terrible I don't understand how a
tourists could go there unless you're a
total [ __ ] and like just Shield
yourself in the reality what's there
because everyone is living a lie right
like when you're in a dictatorship
everyone lives Alive there is no truth
right and like the sort of lie and world
of Lies I tell you is different than the
world idolize I tell somebody else and
then somebody else and then these
running realities you have to remember
it all and keep it all straight in your
head to make sure that you don't step in
the land mine in fact one of my sources
who I was pretty open with that I was
reporting a piece like I didn't lie to
them the piece came out and I wasn't
that anti-government but you know I said
this is what it is they had to like
denounce me on a Facebook post and they
said oh I had no idea that when this
journalist I'd work with them and gave
them a quote that this would happen and
so they had to like denounce me because
I had like violated like the The Matrix
of lies that is living in Cuba and so
that's the reality and again we're not
this isn't Cuba by any stretch but it's
kind of a taste of that feeling of oh I
have to worry about what I say and yeah
have you ever seen the vice documentary
with uh Dennis Rodman in North Korea
[Music]
I'm pretty sure it's Vice does it uh and
this is like when Vice was like real
Vice not like corporate uh Vice
um and in it I just remember this one
scene where uh they walk into a computer
lab and uh they have a bunch of people
on the computers and they're like
but nothing's happening on the computer
and like they like call it out I can't
remember Robin says that are like the
the you know voiceover or whatever but
like it is like very obvious that like
they are trying to put forward a view
that like we have the internet and it's
like let's put some people into a
computer but it almost looks like they
don't know how to use the computers
right and they're just like doing this
action and so that's kind of how I think
of some of these places of just like
yeah it's a play and by the way like if
you were that person ordered to go do
that like you go and you do it right
like of course I want to be a good
soldier like you know let me just type
away on the computer not it's not even
turned on right because because if you
don't you're not going to get your
ration card if you don't you might lose
your job not that anyone ever loses
their job in America for what they
thought or wrote no that never happens
yeah
that is a great place that is a great
place to end this
I will let everyone use their
imagination on that uh go to Wikipedia
um where can we find people to find you
on the internet or find out more about
spindle yeah so I spend way too much
time on Twitter as as we all do uh
Antonio GM Twitter
um I've got a sub stack at
thepoolrequest.com and then fantastic
highly suggest you thank you thank you
and then uh yeah the company spindle
without the e with the e was too
expensive I was like I was gonna pay a
Tesla 3 for a [ __ ] domain no way
we're dropping the E and now it sounds
like a German metal band I might even
add the um loud to have the Motorhead
effect uh but in any case it's spindle
without the e dot XYZ is where it's at
awesome listen thank you so much I could
talk to you literally forever uh
hopefully we both don't get canceled uh
for like the 19th time but exactly I'm
sure we'll do it again in the future
okay thanks Mom